Die Klänge verraten schon, worum es hier heute geht. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, 28. Januar 2009. Ist es eigentlich schicklich jetzt noch zu sagen, gesundes neues Jahr für, wir haben uns ja noch nicht gesehen. Nee, macht man eigentlich nicht mehr, oder?
Aber trotzdem schönes neues.
Dann euch auch. Gut, dann lassen wir den ganzen Mensch in den Kram und steigen sofort ein. Chaos Radio, selbstverständlich. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz, Chaos Computer Club ist hier. Wir sind in der Ausgabe 142, Frank Nibler und Andreas sind da. Nachher werden wir auch noch mit Florian telefonieren. Und das Thema heute, das Internet soll sauberer und damit schöner und familienfreundlicher werden. Es wird also gefordert, zu filtern, zu verbieten und zu zensieren. Frau von der Leyen, unsere Bundesfamilienministerin, hat sich nämlich Anfang des Monats mit deutschen Providern getroffen, mit großen. Und hat mit ihnen auch eine Sperrung bestimmter Seiten im Internet geeinigt. Also die Providers sollen die Seiten schon mal vorab sperren, damit auf die nicht mehr zugegriffen werden kann. Und darum soll es heute gehen, wir fragen uns, was soll vor wem und vor allem wie gesperrt werden, wie soll das eigentlich funktionieren, wie sinnvoll haltet ihr eigentlich diese Zensur, die nicht Zensur heißen soll, im Netz und was passiert, wenn die Technik dazu erstmal installiert ist, wie wir chinesische Verhältnisse kriegen und wie wird das alles weitergehen. Was soll verboten werden im Netz? Was glaubt ihr, was im Netz nicht mehr zu sehen sein sollte? Damit steigen wir gleich mal ein unter der 0331 70 97 110. Habt ihr wie immer die Chance hier mit uns zu sprechen, mit zu diskutieren und eure Anmerkungen abzugeben oder aber ihr klickt chaosradio.ccc.de könnt ihr mitdiskutieren und auch Fragen stellen. Aber vielleicht erst mal von Anfang an die Diskussion um die Sperrung und Filterung und Zensur, die ja nicht Zensur heißen jetzt, kocht ja schon seit Ende letzten Jahres. Seit Ende November geht es glaube ich ernsthafter zur Debatte. Warte Frank, kannst du das kurz mal zusammenfassen, was da los ist?
Also so richtig, wie es dazu gekommen ist, wissen wir gar nicht. Es gab denn nur irgendwann mal die Bemühung, doch jetzt endlich mal was zu tun. Das Thema Kinderpornografie oder sagen wir mal die Dokumentation von Kindesmissbrauch oder die Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch, die Darstellung, ist eine Sache, die immer mal wieder hervorgezogen wird, wenn es darum geht, das Internet zu reglementieren, Zugriffe zu sperren, bestimmte Maßnahmen einzuführen. Da gibt es immer mal wieder Vorführungen, Veranstaltungen, wo Journalisten eingeladen werden. Dann heißt es, schalten Sie bitte Ihre Kameras ab, und dann werden ein paar ganz widerliche Bilder gezeigt. Dann heißt es, sehen Sie das, das gibt es im Internet, das ist da alles zu sehen, wollen wir das? Nein.
Da ist die Meinung einhellig und klar.
Genau, und das sind dann auch wirklich ziemlich widerliche Sachen, die da gezeigt werden, wo dann aber auch meistens nicht mehr gesagt wird, wo genau die herkommen, wie man da normalerweise rankommen würde, wie alt die Sachen sind. Und das sind dann auch so Sachen, die traut man sich dann auch nicht zu fragen. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen das Problem, dass diese ganze Diskussion auch ziemlich tabuisiert wird. Das heißt also, niemand möchte dann auch öffentlich bezichtigt werden, da vielleicht nicht mitzuziehen im Kampf gegen Kinderpornografie. Wenn jetzt ein Provider sagt irgendwie Nö, also das lehnen wir jetzt aus prinzipiellen Erwägungen ab, macht erstmal eine ordentliche Rechtsgrundlage dafür. Also wir machen das nur, wenn es dafür ein Gesetz gibt. Dann heißt es, naja, der unterstützt ja Kinderpornografie. Und das ist eine Sache, das will man sich als Provider natürlich so auch erst mal öffentlich nicht sagen lassen. Und deswegen ist es so ein ziemlich sanftes, aber wirksames Druckmittel, um da einfach so einen gewissen Gruppendruck auch zu erzeugen. Und dann ja, möglicherweise, also ich will jetzt nicht Privatinitiative nennen von unserer Familienministerin, aber es ist schon erstmal der normale juristische Weg, ist es eigentlich nicht. Also dass das Familienministerium sich dann mit den Providern mal auf ein T trifft und sagt, wir hätten da so eine Liste und das würden wir gern, dass die gesperrt wird, die Seiten. Das ist eigentlich nicht der normale Weg für sowas, sondern da müssen Gesetze gemacht werden, da muss es einen formalen Weg geben. Es muss auch sichergestellt sein, dass die Leute, die auf dieser Liste drauf sind, auch dagegen vorgehen können. Das haben wir jetzt bei jugendgefährdenden Medien auch. Die Möglichkeit, da gibt es also ein ganz klares Verfahren, da gibt es eine Kommission, die schreibende Begründung. Dann gibt es eine Rechtsgrundlage. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen die Neuerung, dass es jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen auf einem informellen Weg gemacht wird. Wir haben hier so eine Liste und sperrt die doch mal.
Du sagtest gerade, es gibt keine rechtliche Grundlage, aber es gibt doch ein Gesetz, in dem drin steht, dass die Verbreitung, Darstellung und Misshandlung von Kindern gesetzlich verboten ist, unter Strafe steht und verfolgt wird.
Richtig. Es gibt aber auch noch jede Menge andere Sachen in Deutschland, die verboten sind, die man also nicht darstellen darf. Es gibt Sachen wie zum Beispiel das Glücksspiel im Internet. Das ist auch eine ganz schreckliche Sache, die ist auch verboten. Man denke da an Bilder oder Videos, die waverrechtlich geschützt sind. Also ist hier jeder, aber wo sozusagen die Waver kein Einverständnis gegeben haben, dass sie verbreitet werden. Es gibt also eine ganze Menge Inhalte, die man eigentlich sperren könnte, wo also auf jeden Fall politische Inhalte, Bombenbauanleitungen, ist ja auch immer ganz beliebt. Es gibt also eine ganze Menge Sachen, die man im Internet eigentlich sperren könnte, müsste, weil sie verboten sind.
Also geht es jetzt eigentlich unterm Strich um eine Diskussion darüber, ob bestimmte Inhalte des Internets oder bestimmte Inhalte, die im Web verfügbar sind, pro forma es macht, prophylaktisch verboten werden, nicht zugänglich gemacht werden. Und keiner weiß genau, auf welcher gesetzlichen Grundlage sowas passieren soll. Keiner kann genau sagen, wer entscheidet, was zu verbieten ist. Und darüber wird gerade geredet.
Ja, wir haben im Grundgesetz ja auch nochmal ganz klar festgelegt, in Deutschland findet keine Vorzensur statt, oder keine Zensur in dem Sinne. Wobei es mit der Zensur, muss man also auch so betrachten, dass es sogenannte Vorzensur gibt.
Vorzensur benutzt ja keiner.
Richtig, das wird auch immer versucht, elegant zu umschiffen, sondern es geht einfach darum zu sagen, wir machen eine Sperre und es betrifft nur Kinderpornografie. Aber letztendlich muss man sagen, nach der Definition hier, ist einfach das nicht zugänglich machen von bestimmten Internetinhalten, ist dann an der Stelle eine Zensur. Und ursprünglich ist der Begriff Zensur oder funktioniert er so bei Zeitungen, dass also die Zeitungsredaktion die aktuelle Ausgabe ab einem Zensor vorlegen muss. Und der entscheidet dann, ob das so veröffentlicht werden darf oder nicht. Das ist sogenannte Vorzensur. Und dann haben wir aber eine Sache, die in Deutschland bisher eigentlich die Praxis ist. Wenn es um jugendgefährdende oder schwer jugendgefährdende Medien gibt, dann gibt es ja die Bundesprüfstelle. Und da können dann Sachen vorgeschlagen werden, Inhalte. Das heißt, dazu müssen sie aber erstmal auch da sein. Und dann kann es zum Beispiel ein Jugendamt sein oder auch eine Polizeistelle, die dann sagt, wir sind ja fast gestoßen und das soll mal bitte geprüft werden, ob das jugendgefährdend ist.
Weil die Bundesprüfstelle nicht von sich aus aktiv wird.
Richtig, also der übliche Weg ist, denen wird was vorgeschlagen, da wird was beantragt und dann gibt es dann ein Gremium. Und dann setzen die sich zusammen, gucken sich das gemeinsam an. Muss auch ein ziemlich widerlicher Job sein, würde ich auch nicht machen wollen. Aber die schauen sich dann den ganzen Tag diese Sachen an, was da vorgeschlagen wird. Und dann schreiben sie im Prinzip wie eine Art Gutacht eine Stellungnahme. Und sagen, wir glauben, diese Inhalte gehören indiziert. Die gehören also nicht der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht. Oder zumindest nicht Kinder und Jugendlichen zugänglich gemacht. Weil die und die Gründe vorliegen. Steifer Penis oder Gewaltdarstellungen in besonderer Form. Gewaltverherrlichung. Da gibt es einen Kriterienkatalog und die schreiben eine Begründung dafür. Dann ist das erstmal festgelegt. Dann gibt es eine Indexliste, wo diese Medien drauf erscheinen. Für die darf dann auch nicht mehr öffentlich geworben werden. Die dürfen dann Kinder und Jugendlichen nicht mehr zugänglich gemacht werden. Ich glaube sogar gar nicht. Den Fall haben wir auch. Da muss ich mal kurz zu Andreas rüber gucken.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die tatsächlich verboten werden.
Es gibt ja auch viele Leute, die sagen, es ist okay, wenn sowas verboten wird. Und wenn es nicht zugänglich gemacht wird. Weil es sind einfach Dinge, die verboten sind und die Jugendlichen nicht sehen sollten. Also ist diese Abschaltung von diesen Webseiten oder die Sperrung der Webseiten total in Ordnung. Genauso wie es in Ordnung ist, nach Strafverdächtigen zu suchen. Und damit eine Rassabwarnung durchzuführen. Wenn es zur Ergreifung des Übeltäters führt, dann ist doch das Mittel legitim. Ich selbst hab mir ja nichts vorzuwerfen. Also warum jetzt der große Aufschrei?
Naja, zum einen ist natürlich das Verfahren. Und zum anderen, wie sowas zustande kommt. Und diese Liste kann ja auch lang werden. Also, wenn wir jetzt mal überlegen, mal auf einer Party rumfragen, welche Sachen würdet ihr sperren, so im Internet, vielleicht dies und jenes. Dann könnte man eigentlich auch noch, also die Bombenbauanleitung, ja auf jeden Fall schon auch schon mal, das hat ja überhaupt nichts im Netz zu suchen. Natürlich irgendwelche extremistischen Terroraufrufe, die haben im Netz auch nichts zu suchen, die wollen wir auch gern sperren. So und dann sagen wir, naja, ich bin Musiker, ich lebe davon, meine Musik ist immer im Netz, will ich auch irgendwie sperren, will ich auch nicht, dass das da ist, das ist ja auch verboten. Und diese Liste können wir eigentlich noch beliebig lang machen. Und dann zum Schluss müssen wir uns dann fragen, wie viel vom Internet eigentlich noch übrig ist.
Also geht es eigentlich um die Frage, wieviel Freiheit und wieviel Meinungsfreiheit du dir bereit bist, dir wegnehmen zu lassen, um einen bestimmten Zweck zu erreichen. Eigentlich. Gut, das ist die Diskussion, die wir heute mit euch führen wollen. Hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz, 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Es geht um die angedachte und möglicherweise auch durchzuführende Zensur, die im Internet stattfinden soll. Was denkt ihr, welche Dinge gehören nicht ins Netz? Was sollte rausgenommen werden? Was gehört eurer Meinung nach nicht mehr ins WWW? Da sind wir mal sehr gespannt auf die Sammlungen. 0331 70 97 110. Daniel Steinberg heißt der Mann übrigens, der im Hintergrund Musik macht. Es gibt noch eine Playliste zur Sendung auf fritz.de selbstverständlich. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Heute zum Thema, das Internet soll sauber werden. Es wird gefordert, das Familieninternet zu schaffen mit Filtern, mit Verboten und mit einem Wort, was keiner so in den Mund nimmt, nämlich Zensur. Und wir wollten von euch unter der 0331 70 97 110, das ist die Fritz-Hotline, wissen. Welche Dinge würdet ihr dann gerne im Internet nicht mehr sehen wollten? Was gehört eurer Meinung nach nicht mehr ins Netz? Und uns hat Murat aus Berlin angerufen. Hallo Murat, guten Abend.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Hallo, was gehört deiner Meinung nach nicht ins Internet und könnte gleich mal weggefiltert werden?
Also mir fällt eigentlich erstmal gar nichts ein, was man wirklich wegfiltern müsste, sollte.
Warum?
Weil man dadurch die Probleme nicht an der Wurzelpekt behandelt, sondern nur die Symptome ja entschärfen möchte sozusagen.
Und wie meinst du das?
Naja, wenn ich jetzt, also zum Beispiel jetzt bei der Kinderpornografie, Ziel ist es ja, man will nicht, dass Kinder missbraucht werden. Richtig. Genau. Das verhindert man aber nicht dadurch, dass man die Bilder, die irgendwelche Leute ins Internet stellen, aus dem Netz filtert, damit sie nicht noch andere sehen können, finde ich.
Jetzt ist aber die Argumentation von der Familienministerin so, dass sie sagt, naja, es gibt eine gewisse Nachfrage und dadurch, dass es im Netz so leicht zugänglich ist, steigt die Nachfrage und dadurch wird auch die Produktion angekurbelt. Und wenn man es jetzt schafft, die Nachfrage zu bremsen, zu verringern, dann würde auch die Produktion nicht mehr, oder dann würde es halt kein Geld bringen. Dann lohnt es sich nicht mehr, so was zu produzieren. Und ich würde dann die Kinder schützen.
Wobei die Frage, die dazu auch noch kommt, ist, was heißt eigentlich leicht zugänglich?
Na ja, man muss einfach schon sagen, es ist mittlerweile, also ich hab mal die Analogie überlegt, stell dir mal vor, also Moment, wenn man jetzt irgendwie angenommen man würde irgendwie kiffen und würde Gras kaufen, dann muss man halt irgendwie zum Dealer gehen und irgendwie, das ist halt irgendwie so ein bisschen illegal und schwierig, so das ist halt nicht ganz so leicht zugänglich, als wenn man sich sein Gras per Paypal bezahlen kann und ausdrucken kann zu Hause.
Richtig.
So, dann ist halt schon ein einfacherer Weg. Und so ähnlich ist es mit der Kinderpornografie auch. Natürlich gibt es sie auch schon immer und es gab aber früher Videokassetten und man musste den irgendwie sich von irgendwelchen Bekannten besorgen oder per Post verschicken, dieses Geld musste irgendwie dahin kommen. Und das ist mit dem Internet jetzt schon doch deutlich einfacher geworden.
Aber die, ja, Entschuldigung, Murat.
Also, aber dadurch geht auch, also erstens, wenn man es jetzt nicht verbietet, geht er dadurch auch der Reiz des Verbotes verloren, wodurch eigentlich wieder die Nachfrage sinken müsste, könnte man glauben. Und zum anderen, die Argumentation, die du gerade aufgesetzt hast, die kommt mir ein bisschen skurril vor, also vom Ministerium da. Weil, also in der Wirtschaft ist es ja andersrum. Da richtet sich das Angebot nach der Nachfrage nicht umgekehrt. Und so kam mir gerade die Argumentation, also wenn ich es richtig verstanden hab, die Argumentation gerade vor, dass es andersrum ist.
Ja, die Argumentation ist, wenn wir jetzt diese Seiten wegsperren, dann sinkt auch die Nachfrage, weil die Leute die Sachen nicht mehr sehen.
Ja, aber das klingt für mich nicht logisch. Also wenn ich jetzt Interesse hab an etwas und ich will es haben sozusagen. Und wenn dadurch, dass es schwieriger wird, sinkt nicht wirklich, dass es schwieriger wird, das zu haben, sinkt nicht bei mir das Interesse, sondern dann suche ich mir halt andere Wege und muss mich dann noch mehr informieren, um da ranzukommen. Aber es hindert also, lindert nicht wirklich mein Interesse dann.
Murat, wir halten mal ganz kurz fest, um zusammenzufassen, was du gesagt hast, ein Verbot oder eine Zensur im Netz löst nicht das eigentliche Problem, dass Kinder vor Missbrauch geschützt werden sollen, sondern die Lösung dieses Problems müsste eigentlich ganz woanders ansetzen. Okay, dann danke ich dir erstmal für den Anruf, weil wir haben jetzt André am Telefon, der, glaube ich, in eine ähnliche Richtung geht. Hallo André, grüß dich, guten Abend. Was klappern da bei dir? Hintergrund räumst du gerade?
Ja, meine Freundin hebt hier gerade rum. Also es geht nicht nur in eine ähnliche Richtung, im Großen und Ganzen denke ich, dass das nicht nur das Problem nicht an der Wurzel packt, sondern sogar noch ein zweites Problem schafft. Und so einfach dadurch, dass Filterregeln im Internet, meiner Meinung nach absolut kontraproduktiv gegen die Demokratie arbeiten, allein durch die Tatsache, dass man nicht unbedingt kontrollieren kann, was jetzt gefiltert wird und was nicht. Leuten wird vielleicht auch einfach, werden auch einfach Informationen vorgehalten. Es ist halt dieses chinesische Modell im Endeffekt, wie es ja gerade in China ist. Und wer sich nicht selber eine Meinung bilden kann, kann auch nicht demokratisch entscheiden.
Aber Kinderpornografie ist keine Meinung?
Nee, also ich bin auch absolut gegen Kinderpornografie und ich bin eigentlich sehr viel im Netz unterwegs. Und es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass man irgendwie in jeder Ecke auf irgendeinem Kinderpornobild stößt. Also ich meine, das Problem ist natürlich real. Das sollte man auch nicht runterspielen. Aber im Endeffekt halte ich es doch für sehr übertrieben, da so einen riesen Aufwand zu betreiben. Anstatt sich wirklich mal dahinter zu setzen. Ich meine, in der Vergangenheit ist ja auch genug passiert, Richtung Operation Himmel oder sonst was. Und natürlich verschiedene Schlagworte. In der Richtung, wo das alles einfach nur total scheiße und daneben gelaufen ist. Und anstatt da jetzt einfach so großflächig zuzuschlagen, müsste man sich einfach andere Vorschläge raussuchen. Na gut, das ist jetzt im Endeffekt viele Kinderwohnungswohnungen werden ja auch noch verbreitet über alternative Netzprojekte wie Freenet zum Beispiel. Also nicht der Provider, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das Netzwerk heißt, aber das ist ein Sicherheitsnetzwerk im Endeffekt und das ist ja auch oft negativ in die Schlagzeilen geraten durch Kinderpornografie, weil es halt schlecht rückverfolgbar war.
Also das jetzt zu sagen, um da nochmal rein zu gerätchen, dass das eigentliche Verbot und die Sperrung von Websiten und Providern zu sagen, sie sollen bestimmte Websiten sperren, wie es ja in einigen Ländern gang und gäbe ist, eigentlich nur dazu führt, dass das Ganze verlagert wird und nicht dazu führt, dass es gelöst wird.
Genau, und dazu noch ein weiteres Problem schafft oder schaffen könnte.
Das ist ja einer der Hauptkritikpunkte von Leuten, die jetzt gegen diese mögliche Sperrung oder Anführungszeichen Zensur, wie sie ja nicht heißt, im Internet angehen und dagegen diskutieren. Und worüber wir auch heute hier im Chaosradio auf Ritz diskutieren, welche reellen Möglichkeiten es gibt und vor allen Dingen, wie das rein technisch funktionieren soll. Du hast doch gerade, André, die chinesische Variante erwähnt und erklärt. Siehst du denn die Gefahr, dass sowas bei uns kommen könnte?
Ähm, jetzt noch nicht direkt. Ich sehe die Gefährdung nicht, dass es morgen so sein könnte. Aber ich denke, wenn man so einen Grundstein legt, ist es natürlich einfacher in Zukunft, dass sowas passieren könnte.
Also wenn quasi eine Straße gebaut ist, ist es auch irgendwann normal, dass da Autos drauf fahren werden.
Genau.
Okay, dann danke ich dir erstmal für deinen Anruf. Und einen wunderbaren Abend noch. Und ihr könnt ja auch natürlich gerne mitdiskutieren hier im Chaosradio. 0331 70 97 110. Wir kommen auch gleich zur technischen Variante, wie das eigentlich funktionieren soll. Dass man den Provider anruft und dann sagt, pass auf, hier ist die Liste. Da stehen irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10.000, 15.000 oder 1.000 Internetadressen drauf. Bitte sperrt das dann mal, aber auch in euch noch mal hier im Studio die Frage, ist es denn realistisch, dass es so hier im quasi demokratischen Deutschland oder im demokratischen Deutschland so chinesische Verhältnisse gibt, dass es eine Zensur im Netz gibt und dass, wenn du dein Internet anmachst, dass du möglicherweise nicht die Information bekommst, die du eigentlich gerne haben möchtest?
Also vorstellbar ist ja schon. Wir sehen ja gerade, dass, also damals unter dem Deckmantel des Terrorismus, jetzt wird Kinderpornografie benutzt, also die apokalyptischen Reiter, durchaus Einschränkungen von Freiheitsrechten passieren bei uns, die vorher gar nicht denkbar gewesen wären. Also nur ein klitzekleines Beispiel, das neue BKA-Gesetz gibt dem BKA Rechte eines Geheimdienstes. Auf der anderen Seite steht das BKA nicht unter Kontrolle der Parlamentarischen Kontrollkommission. Das heißt, im Prinzip, das Reichssicherheitshauptamt wurde neu erschaffen. Wir haben eine Exekutive, die nicht mehr durch die Legislative kontrolliert wird. Und deswegen ist diese Angst eigentlich gar nicht weit hergeholt. Und auch wenn man sich anguckt, wie in anderen Ländern, in denen solche Filter-Einrichtungen existieren, damit umgegangen wird, wird man auch sehen, dass Kinderpornografie also einen geringen Teil von dem ausmacht, was tatsächlich gefiltert wird. Und wenn man erstmal den großen roten Knopf geschaffen hat, wo man draufdrücken kann und dann wird was abgeschaltet, dann ist doch die Versuchung da, das zu benutzen.
Gibt es den denn eigentlich schon, diesen roten Knopf? Also gibt es jetzt de facto im Moment, gerade heute an diesem 28. September 2009, die technische Möglichkeit zu sagen, das fliegt bitte aus dem Netz, auf den Knopf zu drücken und dann ist es weg? Also um es möglich zu sagen? Oder gibt es das noch nicht und es geht jetzt darum, das zu schaffen?
Na grundsätzlich ist die technische Realisierung von so Föttermaßnahmen nicht sonderlich aufwendig. Kommt drauf an.
Also es gibt sie aber noch nicht.
Na in Deutschland noch nicht, aber andere Länder haben gezeigt, dass das binnen kürzester Zeit an den Start zu bekommen ist.
Seit den Olympischen Spielen dieses Jahr ist China überall quasi publik gewesen mit der Zensur vom Netz, dass auch Journalisten, die da waren, nicht richtig recherchieren konnten, weil bestimmte Websiten einfach gesperrt waren. China ist als Beispiel gefallen. Was gibt es denn da noch vielleicht auch hier in Europa? Welche Länder haben sowas noch eingeführt?
Großbritannien hat sich da mal sehr beliebt gemacht mit einer Filterung der Wikipedia. Das ging relativ, ja, wohl problemlos für die ASBs das zu tun und ja.
Also es gibt auch andere Länder, die schon Filter haben. Dänemark zum Beispiel, da ist auch die Filterliste mal aufgetaucht. Welche Länder noch?
Also angeblich Schweiz hat wohl auch eine Liste, wobei das ist nicht verifiziert, dass die auch wirklich...
Das ist auch ein großes Problem, dass das ja alles sehr intransparent ist. Es wird nicht drüber geredet, was auf diesen Filterlisten drauf ist, sondern wenn, dann tauchen die halt mal auf aus irgendeiner Quelle. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit zu überprüfen, ob der Content, also wenn der Filter dann aktiv ist und ich mich als Staatsbürger davon überzeugen will, dass diese Filterung berechtigt ist, kann ich das gar nicht, weil es wird ja gefiltert. Das heißt, wer auch immer da auf den Knopf drückt, kann mir erzählen, naja, das ist ganz böser Content und dann kann ich das nicht mehr überprüfen.
Du hast gerade erwähnt, dass immer mal wieder Listen auftauchen aus irgendwelchen Quellen. Stehen denn da nur die Seiten drauf, um die es jetzt eigentlich geht? Also Seiten mit Kinderpornografie, mit Kindesmisshandlung oder sind auch schon andere Seiten mit dabei?
Das ist denke ich mal ein grundsätzliches Problem, da diese Listen nicht öffentlich verfügbar sind, aus augenscheinlich gutem Grund kann da auch keine Kontrolle stattfinden. Also man kann da nicht sicher sein, dass da nicht Seiten drauf stehen, die eigentlich mit Kinderpornografie und so weiter nichts zu tun haben, sondern aus ganz anderen Gründen da drauf stehen.
Also ist diese Liste aus Dänemark, die ist jetzt schon ein Jahr alt und ich hab da mal geklickt und es gibt diese Webseiten schlicht und da greifen alle nicht mehr. Weil ist klar, wenn man eine Seite betreibt, die aus irgendeinem Grund gefiltert wird, dann zieht man halt auf eine andere URL um.
Wie diese Filterung rein technisch funktioniert und was es da an Sachen gibt im Hintergrund noch zu wissen, das klären wir gleich im Chaosradio nach den Nachrichten, die wir jetzt gleich haben werden mit Wetter und Verkehr. Und ihr seid natürlich eingeladen, weiter hier anzurufen und mit zu diskutieren unter der 0331 für Potsdam, das ist die Vorwahl. Und dann 70 97 110. Das Chaosradio heute auf Fritz zum Thema Familieninternet filtern, verbieten, zensieren.
Manchmal kommt neue Musik nicht aus den Chants, sondern genau dahin, wo ihr wohnt.
Auch nach Potsdam?
Die Fritz-DJs machen Party in den besten Clubs von hier und in der Gegend.
Two, one, diesen Samstag.
Fritz-Info.
Mit Keitern Drüllich.
Entschuldigung, da war das Mikro noch nicht offen. Im Zeiten der internationalen Finanz- und Wirtschaftskrise hat in Devis das Weltwirtschaftsforum begonnen. Bei der Eröffnung warnte der russische Minister Präsident Putin vor zu starken Eingriffen des Staates in die Wirtschaft. Dabei hat er auf Erfahrung in der Sowjetunion hingewiesen. Bis zum Sonntag tauschen sich in Devis 2500 Persönlichkeiten aus Politik und Wirtschaft über die aktuellen Entwicklungen aus. Wer morgen mit dem Zug fahren will, sollte sich auf Behinderungen einstellen. In insgesamt neun Städten wollen morgen früh Bahnmitarbeiter streiken. Auch Berlin ist davon betroffen. S- und U-Bahnen sowie Busse werden aber normal fahren. Die Gewerkschaften Transnet und GDBA haben angekündigt, dass bis in den späten Vormittag hineingestreikt werden soll und dass deswegen Züge zu spät kommen oder ausfallen werden. Mit dem Streik soll Druck im Tarifstreit gemacht werden, bei dem es laut den Gewerkschaften nicht vorangeht. In Berlin-Mitte haben am Abend mehrere Hundert Menschen gegen eine sogenannte Mahnwache der NPD demonstriert. Unter dem Motto Stop den Holocaust in Gaza wollten die Rechtsextremisten schon gestern am Holocaustgedenktag gegen Israel demonstrieren. Das hat die Polizei aber untersagt. Einige Rechtsextremisten haben sich stattdessen vor dem Bahnhof Friedrichstraße versammelt, wo auch die Gegendemonstranten eintrafen. Auf ihrer Kundgebung hatte der Präsident des Abgeordnetenhauses Momba noch einmal ein Verbotsverfahren gegen die NPD gefordert. Die Datenschutzaffäre bei der Deutschen Bahn ist weitaus größer als bislang vermutet. Der Konzern gab zu, heimlich mehr als 170.000 Mitarbeiter und damit fast drei Viertel seiner Belegschaft auf Hinweise für Korruption überprüft zu haben. Daten wie Adressen, Telefonnummern und Bankverbindungen seien mit Daten von Firmen abgeglichen worden, zu denen die Bahn Geschäftsbeziehungen hatte. Die Mitarbeiter sollen ohne einen konkreten Verdacht überprüft und hinterher auch noch nicht mal darüber informiert worden sein. Energie Cottbus ist aus dem DFB Pokal ausgeschieden. Energie Cottbus unterlag Leverkusen mit 1 zu 3. In einem weiteren Spiel besiegte Bremen noch Dortmund mit 2 zu 1. Damit rücken Bremen und Leverkusen ins Viertelfinale des DFB Pokals vor. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen heute Abend. In Angermünde haben wir minus 5 Grad. Frankfurt, Wittenberg und Neuruppin, da sind es minus 4. Potsdam und Cottbus minus 3 und auch in Berlin minus 3 Grad. In dieser Nacht geht es mit den Temperaturen weiter bergab, nämlich mit Tiestwerten zwischen minus 1 und minus 5 Grad. Dazu kommt noch etwas Nebel. Der Rest der Woche bleibt neblig trüb. Nachts bleibt es meist frostig und tagsüber trocken. Morgen dann haben wir Temperaturen von maximal plus 2 Grad. Derzeit keine Mählung von den Straßen. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn im Radio 101, 5?
Dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Playlisten wie gesagt bei fritz.de. Aber wir wollen ja keine Musik hören, sondern wir wollen reden mit euch. Chaosradio ist heute wieder da am letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit Frank, mit Nibbler, mit Andreas. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir werden nachher auch noch mit Florian vom ScusiBlock sprechen, denn es geht heute um Zensur im Netz. Aufhänger ganz kurz, was bisher geschah, um Kinder vor Missbrauch und vor Pornografie zu schützen, plant die Bundesfamilienministerin Ursula von der Leyen eine Sperrung von Webseiten durch die Provider. Das ist mittlerweile in der Diskussion. Kinderpornografie soll gefiltert werden, aber mittlerweile gibt es auch schon andere Befindlichkeiten. In Hessen gab es zum Beispiel den Wunsch, auch Internetseiten mit ausländischen Lotterien aus dem Netz rauszunehmen, weil die auch nicht erwünscht werden. Und irgendwann besteht natürlich die große Sorge, bei vielen haben wir dann chinesische Verhältnisse mit einem zensierten Internet. Was haltet ihr davon? Welche Seiten sollten im Netz verboten werden? Und was haltet ihr von der geplanten Zensur im Netz? Darüber könnt ihr hier mit uns diskutieren. 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon, am Telefon ist Timo. Was hältst du von der geplanten Zensur?
Ja, also ich halte von einer Zensur erst mal gar nichts, weil es gibt immer genug Ausweichmöglichkeiten, wie zum Beispiel ausländische Domains oder Web-Speicherplätze, die komplett anonym sind und wo sich die Leute dann auch direkt verstecken. Und dazu kommt noch, dass die Leute komplett nicht gefunden werden können.
Das verhindert aber bestenfalls die Strafverfolgung. Zensieren kann man das trotzdem.
Bitte, das kam akustisch nicht an.
Das verhindert bestenfalls die Strafverfolgung. Aber zensieren kann man das trotzdem.
Die Zensur ist dann aber nur für einen Großteil da. Sonst gibt es immer Möglichkeiten über ein Proxy, dass die Leute trotzdem die Webseiten anstreuen können.
Aber da ist ja das Argument von unserer Familienministerin, dass es darum geht, erstmal die breite Masse davon abzuklemmen. Es ist schon bewusst, dass es immer Leute gibt, die da irgendwie auch an die Sachen rankommen. Aber es geht darum, die Nachfrage auszutrocknen.
Richtig. Aber es ist genauso mit den Musiksachen und Videos. Die werden auch irgendwo ausgetaucht. Und da ist es wirklich ein Problem, dass das Internet immer ein bisschen schneller ist. Oder gerade die Leute, die sich damit sehr viel beschäftigen.
Also sind wir bei dem Argument, was wir kurz vor den Nachrichten schon mal hatten, dass die eigentliche Zensur oder die Sperrung von Webseiten, die jetzt geplant ist, überhaupt nicht dahin führt, wo sie eigentlich gerne hinkommen wollen, sondern eigentlich eher in die falsche Richtung geht.
Das denke ich mal auch. Und es ist genauso wie mit Kriminellen mit einer Waffe oder so. An eine Waffe kommt jeder ran. Egal was man möchte, das bekommt man auch. Und da gibt es für solche Leute nie so ein Problem. Die kommen immer irgendwo ran. Und solche Gesetze werden immer nur die Leute schützen, die weniger Ahnung haben. Aber derjenige, der wirklich Geld hat oder auch die Dacht hat, wird immer was erreichen können. Und genauso ist es im Internet, dass die Leute auch an ihre Sachen rankommen, was sie machen möchten. Und mit Kinderpornografie, das wird natürlich auch immer öfter irgendwo aufgedeckt. Aber es gibt immer wieder die Stellen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel mit Handys oder so, dass wir da rüber ausgetauscht werden. Gut, dass wir sowas gefunden haben oder die Leute entdeckt haben. Aber es gibt immer wieder neue Möglichkeiten, wo sie sich verstecken können.
Also um es kurz noch mal zusammenzufassen in zwei Worten, die Verhältnismäßigkeit der Zensur im Internet hältst du für überzogen oder für falsch oder für richtig?
Also ich halte es auch für falsch in dem Sinne, es gibt auch Seiten, die beschäftigen sich zum Beispiel mit solchen Dingen und berichten darüber, die dementsprechend vielleicht auch gesperrt werden dadurch. Weil wenn es eine automatische Zensur gibt, dann würden die in diese Trasse auch reinfallen. Und dementsprechend werden die Seiten dann vielleicht mal für ein paar Tage raus oder auch ganz erstmal raus, bis dann jemand irgendwo was mitkriegt oder auch den Behördengang durchkriegt, dass er dementsprechend seine Seite wieder frei kriegt.
Beziehungsweise sie ziehen auf eine andere Domain um, was du am Anfang ja erwähnt hast. Und dann wären wir wieder am Anfang des Weges. Timo, erstmal vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Der nächste am Telefon ist Tom. Ich glaube, der hat eine ähnliche Wortmeldung. Hallo Tom, guten Abend. Hallo? Hallo Tom, Abend. Hallo.
Ja, also meine Meinung weckt sich da ziemlich gut. Also wenn man anfängt, jetzt unter dem Vorwort Kinderpornografie, was ja egal zu welchem Thema immer herangezogen wird, egal was es ist, ob es eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder jetzt die Zensur ist, ist ja immer Kinderpornografie das große Übel. Aber wenn man jetzt zensiert, ich meine Leute, die jetzt auf Kinderpornografie stehen, die sind krank. Und die heilt man dadurch nicht, dass man ihnen mit dem Zugang in Anführungsstrichen verwertet, was natürlich auch Schwachsinn ist, weil wer es wirklich will, kommt wie mein Vorredner ja gesagt hat auch wirklich ran. Also es ist vollkommen bescheuert.
Also sollten wir vielleicht auch erst mal klären, und das machen wir jetzt hier genau an dieser Stelle in der Sendung, wie diese Zensur, wenn sie dann da durchkommen würde, wie das denn funktioniert, dass man eine Webseite dann sperrt. Frank, wie soll das gehen?
Naja, also ich gucke mal hier unsere Experten ran, die eigentlich täglich mit dem Netz arbeiten. Wie würdet ihr denn so eine Sperre einrichten? Also was wäre jetzt euer Ansatz? Ihr kriegt jetzt arbeitet bei einem Provider und sagen hier so eine Liste.
Von wem kommt die Liste eigentlich?
Also in Deutschland ist der Plan, dass das Bundeskriminalamt diese Liste machen soll.
Und die wird ihnen dann zugearbeitet von Internstellenbehörden?
Ja, das ist so eine große Frage.
Das ist noch nicht ganz raus. Glücklicherweise haben wir gut informierte Leute im Chat. Mir wurde gerade gesagt, dass am 23. Januar die Arbeitsgruppe zum ersten Mal tagte, die also die Änderung des Telemediengesetzes entwirft.
Genau, die war aber nicht öffentlich, diese Sitzung.
Also nichts Genaues weiß man noch nicht. Also es ist zu hoffen, dass es wenigstens so ist, dass es dann einen vernünftigen Rechtsweg gibt, dass es eine Möglichkeit gibt, an diese Listen ranzukommen, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, zu klagen. Es besteht natürlich Grund zu der Annahme, dass es nicht so sein wird.
Gut, also es gibt irgendwie Listen.
Genau, es gibt eine Liste. Da stehen Webseiten drauf. Genau, also vielleicht stehen da Webseiten, auch ganze URLs, also nochmal ganz kurz, um die Begriffe auch nochmal zu klären. Also es gibt eine Webseite, ist so allgemein, das, was man irgendwo www.fritz.de, so das ist eine Webseite, wo man rauf geht und da hat man dann meistens eine Homepage, irgendwie mit irgendwas drauf. Und eine URL, Uniform Resource Locator, bezeichnet also eine spezifische Seite oder einen spezifischen Inhalt. Das kann also ein Bild sein, das kann eine Webseite sein, wobei auf die Webseite bezieht sich dann in der Regel erstmal nur auch auf die eine Seite tatsächlich. Also nur mal diese Begrifflichkeit zu machen. Wenn ich es jetzt richtig verstanden hab.
Also ich kann eine Webseite anschalten, aber die URL bleibt trotzdem da.
Genau, oder ich kann zum Beispiel, wenn ich eine Webseite hab, zum Beispiel bei Wikipedia in England, da war es so, dass wirklich nur ein Bild gesperrt worden ist. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Oder es wäre zumindest die Möglichkeit zu sagen, das Bild zeigt irgendwie eine kinderpornografische Darstellung.
Es ging da um einen Plattencover von einem 78. Die Virgin Killer, auf der ein junges Mädchen nackt dasteht. Das ist jetzt 1978, also quasi nach 30 Jahren, dann aufgefallen, dass das jetzt plötzlich ins Raster fällt. Und das wurde vorsorglich aus dem Netz genommen.
Genau, dann gäbe es die Möglichkeit zu sagen, den Artikel drum herum lassen wir stehen, sondern wir wollen jetzt nur dieses eine Bild sperren. Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, genau diese URL rauszusuchen von diesem Bild und die dann in eine entsprechende Filterliste zu tun. Ja, genau, wie geht es denn weiter?
Wir haben also jetzt die Liste und die geht vom BKA dann zum, weiß ich nicht, Provider, wem auch immer. Woher wissen die eigentlich, welchen Provider die anschreiben sollen?
Richtig, also da geht es ja schon mal weiter. Bei dem Vorstoß aus dem Familienministerium geht es darum, diesen sogenannten Access Provider mit denen zu kooperieren. Also ein kleiner Exkurs, wie das Internet funktioniert. Es gibt diese verschiedenen großen Knotenpunkte. Und das, was wir aber als, oder von dem Internet mitkriegen, ist, dass werden wir uns per DSL oder per Modem irgendwo einwählen in der Regel. Das ist dann bei einem Provider. Und das ist dieser Access Provider, der also uns den Access, den Zugang zum Netz gibt, der uns also, der uns unseren Computer mit dem Internet verbindet.
Der dir sozusagen die Abfahrt von der Autobahn baut.
Sozusagen, genau. Und das sind hier bei uns in Deutschland die großen, die online, Alice, Versatel und ein paar zu nennen. Und das sind diese sogenannten Access Provider und um die geht es. Es geht also im Moment nicht darum, irgendwie mit diesen großen Verkehrsknotenpunkten im Internet anzugehen, sondern es geht um die Access Provider, dass also wirklich dann quasi kurz vor meinem Computer dieser Zugang blockiert wird. Genau, wie ist jetzt das Verfahren? Also angenommen, wir sind jetzt Provider und da kommt jetzt das BKA und sagt, ihr postet Briefumschlag auf, da kommt jetzt so eine Liste.
Also ein Provider hat grundsätzlich das Problem, dass er mehrere Dutzend Gigabit an Traffic umsetzt und der muss das irgendwie, also wenn er da eine Filterung vornehmen kann, kann er nicht seinen kompletten Traffic danach durchgucken. So, das ging jetzt zwar technisch, aber es ist viel zu teuer und aufwendig.
Das heißt, da muss jetzt eine Technik geschaffen werden dafür?
Richtig, da muss man sich halt Dinge einfallen lassen. Das fängt an, also in, wo war das, Nordrhein-Westfalen?
Nordrhein-Westfalen, ja, hat man angefangen?
Hatten sie angefangen eben in Domain Name Servern, also die Server, die sowas wie www.fritz.de auf Internetprotokolladressen umwandeln, also diese Nummern 192.168. Und da hat die Filterung eben dadurch in Anführungszeichen funktioniert, dass bestimmte Domains eben auf eine nicht vorhandene IP oder auf was anderes gezeigt haben, dass da eben der Zugang nicht möglich war. Konnte man natürlich einfach umgehen, indem man nicht den Name Servern des Providers verwendet hat, sondern einen anderen, der eben dieses Problem nicht hatte.
Das heißt also, da wurde quasi die Internetadresse oder die Webadresse www.fritz.de auf irgendwo anders hin umgebogen, auf eine Seite der Landesregierung oder sowas, wo so eine Informationsseite kam, wo aber wirklich nicht der Inhalt umgelenkt wurde, sondern nur die Adresse, also der Name umgelenkt wurde.
Was schonmal jetzt das Problem an sich zeigt, wenn es heißt, es müssen Sperrungen von bestimmten Websiten, also bestimmte Websiten sollen gesperrt werden. Das geht ja schonmal da nicht, weil es wird ja nicht die Website gesperrt, sondern die Inhalte der Website.
Das ist eben das Problem, dass man, wenn man so eine IP sperrt, gleich den ganzen Server sperrt und alles, was da drauf liegt. Also bei Wikipedia würde das beispielsweise bedeuten, dass man sowohl dieses Plattencover nicht mehr sieht, als auch die ganzen anderen sinnvollen Inhalte der Wikipedia.
Ja, DNS-Filter sind übrigens das, was in den skandinavischen Ländern schon eingesetzt wird. Also es gibt da den Child Sexual Abuse Anti-Distribution Filter, der CSKADF, der CIRCAM-Gruppe für die Bekämpfung von Cybercrime und Kinderpornografie auf EU-Ebene.
Und was macht das Ding?
Das macht genauso ein DNS-Filter. Also es gibt Listen, die verteilt werden zwischen den Ländern. Und ja, es ist alles dabei. Dänemark, Belgien, Frankreich, Finnland, Irland, Italien, Malta, Niederlande, Polen, Schweden, Spanien. Die machen das also alle schon. Das war genau so.
Wir hatten ja gerade, Nibler hat ja gerade erwähnt, Provider hat eine Menge Traffic und irgendwie muss das, also die können ja nicht den ganzen Traffic durchgucken. Das ist ein riesen Aufwand. Die technischen Gegebenheiten sind im Moment noch nicht so richtig da. Die werden gerade entwickelt. Wo ist der Unterschied zu dem Filter, den du gerade genannt hast?
Na, der DNS-Filter filtert tatsächlich nur die komplette Website raus.
Das Filter filtert eigentlich gar nicht, sondern der lenkt nur um. Das ist vom Aufwand her minimal. Das kann man in der Mittagspause implementieren. Trägt man halt die Liste ein in seinen Nameserver und gut ist. Da wird nicht aktiv irgendwie Traffic angeguckt und beiseite geworfen, sondern wirklich nur dem User quasi eine andere Adressiername.
Allerdings ist es durchaus so, dass die Filterung des kompletten Traffics immer mehr handhabbar wird. Das heißt, dass moderne Switches und Router also hat angefangen dafür, dass man Traffic-Shaping macht, weil die Probeider gesagt haben, ja, die Leute sollen nicht so viel File sharen, das macht die Bandbreite so zu, wir wollen lieber anderen Traffic priorisieren. Und ob man jetzt Voice-Over-IP-Telefonie schnell macht oder ob man bestimmte Webseiten rausfiltert, ist letzten Endes technisch dasselbe. Das heißt, dass man also tatsächlich in die Pakete, die da durchgehen, reinguckt, weit reinguckt bis auf Protokollebene runter und sagt, naja, das ist gerade ein HTTP-Request, der läuft auf eine URL, die ich nicht mag, da wird die rausgefiltert.
Und in dem Moment, wo das auch nicht mehr Spezial-Hardware ist, in dem Moment, wo wir eine Nachfrage haben, man muss sich da nach China angucken, die haben genau das, eben eine Nachfrage nach Filter-Hardware, wird auch die Hardware günstiger und günstigere Hardware ermöglicht natürlich mehr Leuten, aktiv zu filtern.
Die Geräte, um die es geht, die werden eigentlich vertrieben unter Netzwerkmanagement-Geräte oder das sind nicht Geräte.
Policy Enforcement.
Policy Enforcement, ja, da gibt es also verschiedene schöne Begriffe.
Also gibt es auch einen großen Markt dafür, wo es gerade eine Menge Nachfrage dafür gibt, da gibt es also auch Geld zu verdienen.
Da gibt es auch Geld zu verdienen, die Dinge, wobei sie sind eigentlich erschreckend günstig geworden, muss man einfach auch so sagen. Es sind natürlich immer noch, also jetzt, es sind schon fünf- sechsstellige Beträge für so einen großen Provider, also eher dann sechsstellige für einen großen oder siebenstelliger, die da auf so einen Provider dazukommen, weil wir haben einfach wahnsinnige Bandbreiten. Und wenn die Leute zu Hause am Losklicken sind, abends um 20 Uhr, um 21 Uhr, dann passiert da auch richtig was im Netz. Und das ist jetzt nicht ganz so einfach. Und deswegen beschweren sich natürlich auch die Provider zurecht. Die sagen ja, wer bezahlt denn das eigentlich, wenn wir hier eure extra Würste noch braten?
Da kommt ja das Familienministerium wieder ins Spiel und sagt, wenn ihr da extra Geld braucht, wir würden das auch irgendwie mitfinanzieren und mit unterstützen. Aber um es nochmal ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, wir haben jetzt also drei Positionen. Wir haben zwar auf der einen Seite die Regierung oder die Gesetzgebung, die sagt, es muss eine Filterung oder soll eine Filterung bzw. Sperrung von verschiedenen Webseiten, Inhalten geben. Auf der zweiten Seite gibt es die Provider, die sagen, da ist so viel Traffic unterwegs, es ist im Moment technisch nicht möglich, sowas zu machen. Und auf der dritten Seite gibt es die Skandinavier und die Chinesen und wer auch immer, die mit den DNS-Filtern arbeiten. Warum gibt es da unterschiedliche Systeme? Warum gibt es da keine Vereinheitlichung? Oder andersherum gefragt, warum geht nicht einfach das Bundesfamilienministerium klopft in Skandinavien bei den Kollegen an und sagt, wie macht ihr das, wollen wir auch?
Also die haben sich das zumindest von denen mal zeigen lassen. Es besteht Grund zu der Annahme, dass sie es genauso machen. Mittlerweile sind die Provider ja auch weich geworden. Die haben kein Bock mehr und haben gesagt, na gut, dann stellen wir halt so eine Kiste hin. Und es haben sich also die ersten Provider schon gefunden für ein Pilotprojekt, um das mal technisch zu testen. Also leider ist über diese Geldschiene nicht mehr viel zu reißen, sondern man muss dann endlich wirklich über die eigentlichen Probleme solcher Filterinfrastruktur nachdenken.
Das ist ja auch grundsätzlich so, wenn die Provider den Auftrag bekommen, filtert das mal weg, so ganz generisch. Macht mal, wir kümmern uns da nicht um die technischen Details. Das könnt ihr mal lösen, finden die auch günstige Wege. In Großbritannien ist diese Wikipedia-Filterung dadurch gelöst worden, dass sie einen Proxy-Server hingestellt haben und dann gezielt nur den Traffic, der zu Wikipedia geht, über diesen Proxy-Server geleitet haben. Also ein Zwischenserver, wo man irgendwie seine HTTP-Verbindung hinmacht und dann macht der eine zu Wikipedia und reicht einem den Inhalt durch. Und da haben sie eben das Bild gesperrt, was dann zum lustigen Problem geführt hat, dass alle Edits aus Großbritannien von diversen Einwahl-Providern von einer IP kamen.
Das macht das Internet kaputt.
Es ist schwierig in der Wikipedia dann zu sagen, wer das genau und einzelne Abuser zu sperren und das zuzuordnen. Also das geht hinten und vorne nicht.
Wunderbar, kann man nur ganz klar sagen, das macht das Internet kaputt, wenn dann plötzlich alle Anfragen von einer IP-Adresse kommen. Das war nicht gedacht mit dem Netz.
Dass alle Leute überall mitarbeiten und überall Zugriffe haben.
Nee, dass alle Leute, dass alle Zugriffe von einer IP-Adresse kommen, weil sie nämlich über diesen zentralen Sperrfilter geht, wo dann alle zwangsweise drübergeleitet werden, um bestimmte Inhalte rauszufiltern. Das ist ja auch eine Sache, weiß nicht, in Firmen oder sowas ist es so üblich. Aber da kann man ja sagen, okay, die Leute sollen nicht den ganzen Tag irgendwelchen Quatsch klicken, die werden ja schließlich dafür bezahlt, oder eben nicht dafür bezahlt. Deswegen machen wir mal sowas in der Firma, dass wir einfach bestimmte Sachen rausfiltern. Wenn es entsprechend im Arbeitsvertrag geregelt ist, kann man sagen, gut, es ist in Ordnung, aber im Internet wollen wir sowas bitte nicht haben.
Die technischen Aspekte der Sperre haben wir jetzt ganz kurz beleuchtet. Wir haben wieder Anrufer. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Am Telefon ist Alva. Guten Abend, grüß dich. Du musstest jetzt ein bisschen warten. Wir haben uns in der Technik etwas verloren. Hallo, Alva. Was hältst du denn von der ganzen Thematik?
Ja, ich denke, es hört sich ja erstmal schön an, wenn man sagt, okay, wir müssen was gegen missbrauchte Kinder machen. Da ist ja erst mal normalerweise kein vernünftiger Mensch dagegen. Wenn man sich das ein bisschen mehr anschaut, dann muss man sich eine wichtige Frage stellen. Und die muss man sich bei jeder Maßnahme stellen. Die man macht, ist das verhältnismäßig. Und dazu gehören drei wichtige Punkte. Nämlich der erste Punkt, ist es überhaupt geeignet? Ist der Zweck, der damit erreicht werden soll, kann der damit erreicht werden? Und wenn man sich das genauer betrachtet, dann kann dieser Zweck, nämlich die Produktion von Kinderpornografie und den Missbrauch von Kindern einzudämmen, damit gar nicht erreicht werden. Die Begründung ist ja, dass je weniger Nachfrage entsteht, desto weniger Kinder werden missbraucht. Jetzt ist es aber nicht so, dass Kinderpornografie im Internet sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass sie durch besonders offene Präsenz glänzt. Sondern das wird ja alles in versteckten Zirkeln getauscht. Meistens über Chat und über Instant Messaging und per E-Mail und ähnlichen Verfahren. Die Sachen kann man mit den angesprochenen Techniken sowieso schon mal nicht sperren.
Also ist die Gefahr oder der Gedanke durchaus berechtigt, dass wenn die Technik erst mal installiert ist, durchaus auch aus anderen Sachen gleich mal mit weggefiltert werden können? Weil nun ist es ja schon da.
Genau, es ist ganz klar, es geht letztendlich überhaupt nicht um Kinderpornografie. Es geht entweder um Wahlkampf und um Profilierung oder es geht um andere Bereiche. Glücksspiel, da gab es ja auch schon Vorstöße aus Hessen, um die Sachen zu sperren, die Musikindustrie ist ganz wild darauf. Es gibt sehr viele Interessengruppen, die das eine oder das andere gefiltert haben möchten, aus mehr oder weniger gutem Grund. Da kommt natürlich auch der Wind her, weil bei Kinderpornografie kann der Zweck gar nicht erreichbar sein. Und die nächste Frage ist ja, ob es überhaupt erforderlich ist, ob man kein milderes Mittel finden kann.
Was heißt milderes Mittel?
Kein milderes Mittel für die Nutzer in diesem Falle, beziehungsweise natürlich ein besseres Mittel, um gegen die Inhalte vorzugehen. Was wäre ein besseres Mittel? Natürlich gegen die Anbieter vorgehen. Also die Inhalte komplett aus dem Netz entfernen, sofern sie öffentlich zugänglich sind. Aber genau das wird ja nicht gemacht. Wir haben auf den skandinavischen Listen Tausende von Webseiten drauf. Und diese Tausenden von Webseiten liegen zu einer überwiegend großen Mehrheit in westlichen Staaten.
Das ist in der Tat richtig. Also da muss man zwei Dinge unterscheiden. Zum einen die Strafverfolgung auf der einen Seite und zum anderen die Nichtverfügbarmachung durch Fehtermassnahmen auf der anderen Seite. Das sind zwei ganz deutlich zu trennende Maßnahmen. Auch mit einem augenscheinlich unterschiedlichen Impact.
Genau. Also ich meine, wenn man sich die Sachen mal anschaut. Ich hatte am Wochenende, weil ich auf einem Seminar zu diesem Thema war und einen Workshop gemacht hab, mir mal die von den in Finnland geleigten Seiten, die deutschen, die in Deutschland gehosteten angeschaut. Und die sind tatsächlich in Deutschland gehostet.
Das heißt, es ist relativ einfach, wenn du weißt, wo die Seiten sind, relativ einfach nachzuvollziehen. Wer steckt eigentlich hinter dieser Seite?
Das ist in wenigen Sekunden feststellbar, wo die Seite gehostet ist. Oder zumindest, wo der entsprechende Anschlussknoten-Sitz jemand abschalten kann.
Weil wenn nur die Seite abgeschaltet wird, sucht sich der Betreiber einfach eine neue. Um es ganz einfach zu sagen. Oder einen neuen Weg.
Der kann sich auf jeden Fall eine neue Sache suchen. Außer er sitzt im Knast, wenn er strafrechtlich verurteilt wurde. Also wenn man sich auf einmal diese Seiten mal anschaut, die da drin sind, und bei einer deutschen Seite gehe ich mal davon aus, dass wenn die auf einer europäischen Filterliste drauf ist, dass dort kein illegales Material drauf ist. Und ich meine, das war natürlich inhaltlich grenzwertig, was da zu sehen ist, aber es ist vermutlich nicht illegal. Und wenn es illegal wäre, dann wäre es natürlich der korrekte Weg, in Frankfurt, da wo der Server steht, den Hobbs zu nehmen. Und den verantwortlichen Betreiber zu verhaften. Aber genau das passiert nicht. Offensichtlich, weil es den Strafverfolgungsbehörden bewusst ist, dass das nicht wirklich illegal ist, sondern nur halt entsprechend geschmacklos. Die Landeskriminalämter sind sich auch noch nicht mal einig, was jetzt wirklich als Kinderpornografie einzustufen ist. Zum Beispiel in Nordrhein-Westfalen gelten Texte, obwohl es der Gesetzestext anders sagt, nicht als Kinderpornografie in Baden-Württemberg und Bayern schon. Da hatte ich letztens ein interessantes Telefonat mit einem Menschen vom LKA aus Düsseldorf. Also da sind sehr viele Unwägbarkeiten. Und da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein, was dann, wo, in welchem Kontext als Kinderpornografie aufgefasst wird. Und der letzte Punkt ist natürlich, es muss angemessen sein, eine solche Sperre. Also es dürfen keine gravierenden Nachteile entstehen. Und die Wikipediasperre hat ja gezeigt, es gibt Nachteile, wenn man sich die Filterlisten aus den skandinavischen Ländern oder aus Großbritannien, was öffentlich bekannt wurde, anschaut. Sehen wir auch, dass da viele Nachteile sind, weil einfach Inhalte drauf sind, die offensichtlich nicht strafbar sind. Und gleichzeitig ist so ein Filtersystem etabliert natürlich, es wird nicht nur für Kinderpornografie oder vermeintliche Kinderpornografie genutzt. Es ist ganz klar, es wäre sicherlich auch nicht haltbar, es dann nicht für andere entsprechende Inhalte zu nutzen, wie die Liste der Bundesprüfstelle für jugendgefährdende Medien und so weiter.
Ich würde gerne noch mal ganz kurz an den Punkt einhaken, den du am Anfang gesagt hast, Alba, und zwar, dass es natürlich das Argument Kinderpornografie, da gibt es eigentlich kein Argument dagegen anzugehen, weil das ist ein Thema, wo alle Leute dagegen sind, dass so etwas verbreitet wird. Klar, aber es gibt im Moment jede Menge Leute, die sich natürlich auch für diese Filterregeln interessieren, die Interesse daran haben, bestimmte Seiten aus dem Netz zu nehmen. Also seien es die Lottoseiten in Hessen, sei es die Musikindustrie, sei es wer auch immer. Und dass daher eigentlich der Wind wehen könnte, das ist ein Argument, was wir hier in der Sendung sicherlich noch verfolgen werden.
Ja, also es ist sicherlich ganz klar, dass da auch die Lobbyisten am Werk sind. Wer jetzt für den neuen Vorstoß nun wirklich verantwortlich ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Aber die Musikindustrie versucht es schon seit Jahren. Aber es gibt auch natürlich diverse Anwälte, die sich mit Persönlichkeitsrecht befassen und dann wollen, dass die britische Sanne in Deutschland nicht mehr erreichbar ist, weil da ihr Mandant irgendwie beleidigt wird und so weiter. Es gibt viele mehr oder minder legitime Interessen natürlich auch. Aber es muss natürlich unterscheiden zwischen Verbreit und Empfangen. Und da haben wir vom Grundgesetz her auch eine abgestufte Verantwortlichkeit. Nämlich verbreiten darf man nicht alles, aber lesen darf man eigentlich alles.
Ja, wunderbar. Danke, soweit erstmal. Wir werden gleich nochmal ein bisschen genauer der Frage nachgehen, wo diese Server dann stehen mit dem Material drauf, die gesperrt werden sollen.
Für Alva ja eben schon gesagt, dass ein großer der Server hier in Deutschland steht und damit einfacher nachzuvollziehen sein könnte.
Da gibt es nämlich jemand, der hat sich mal ganz genau angeschaut, wo diese Server dann stehen, wo die Sachen herkommen. Und das werden wir dann auch gleich mal klären, ob es da nicht doch Möglichkeiten gäbe, da direkt ranzukommen.
Das klären wir gleich. 0331 70 97 110. Das ist die Telefonnummer von Blue Moon hier auf Fritz vom Chaosradio. Alva, dir erstmal vielen Dank und schönen Abend noch.
Alles klar, schönen Abend.
Zeit für die elektronische Zeitansage. Der Chaos Computer Club wünscht einen wunderbaren letzten Mittwoch im Monat, deswegen sind wir hier. Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Frank, Nibbler und Andreas sind da. Wir werden auch gleich noch mit Florian reden vom ScusiBlog. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, mitzudiskutieren zum heutigen Thema Zensur im Internet. Welche Seiten sollten verboten werden? Was gehört alles nicht ins Netz? 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste Anrufer ist Stefan, muss es auch eine Weile warten. Ich hoffe, es ist nicht so schlimm. Hallo Stefan, guten Abend.
Erstmal guten Abend an alle.
Zur Frage, die wir hier auch schon immer wieder mal angesprochen haben, nämlich, dass unterschiedliche Filter angewendet werden, aber nicht so richtig klar ist, wer diese Filter eigentlich aufstellt.
Ja, erstmal Asche über mein Haupt, ich habe noch nicht die ganze Sendung zugehört. Ja, aber fangen wir mal an.
Kannst du als Podcast nochmal hören.
Für mich ist die Frage eigentlich, wer genau bestimmt jetzt, wie gesagt, die Filterregeln, wie du eben schon gesagt hast. Weil es ist ja immer die Frage, zum Beispiel so bei Kinderpornografie, wann fängt Kinderpornografie an und wann hört so Pornografie auf, irgendwie. Also das ist die Frage eigentlich immer. Und ich sag mal, das ist immer ziemlich im Auge des Betrachters irgendwie. Und da ist es ziemlich schwierig, irgendwie ein objektives Urteil zu fällen.
Weil bislang waren wir ja an dem Standpunkt, okay, also es gibt eine Liste mit Webseiten oder mit URLs, die bedenkliche Inhalte haben. Diese Liste geht dann vom BKA an die Provider und die werden sich dann weiterhin darum kümmern. Besonders es läuft über DNS-Filter, wie Andreas schon erklärt hat. Aber die Frage ist natürlich berechtigt, wer bestimmt diese Filterregeln?
Also wir haben am Anfang schon mal versucht, diese Begrifflichkeit Kinderpornografie noch mal ein bisschen schärfer zu fassen. Wie wir gesagt haben, das ist eine Dokumentation, eine Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch. Also um vielleicht auch noch mal ganz klar zu Pornografie zu trennen, die ja auch zumindest bei uns in Deutschland, das ist ja auch nicht überall auf der Welt so, jetzt erst mal relativ liberal gehandhabt wird. Also man kann einfach in eine Videothek gehen, sich da irgendwie einen Pornofilm holen. Also voll Erotik, wie es ja auch so schön heißt. Also wo dann auch wirklich alles komplett zu sehen ist.
Also es ist nicht strafbar.
Keine Kinder, keine Tiere, keine Toten.
Und um das einfach mal von der Begrifflichkeit ein bisschen zu trennen. Also einfach zu sagen, okay, da werden irgendwie Kinder missbraucht. Das klingt vielleicht auch noch mal oder ist einfach noch mal begrifflich vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen geschärft von Kinderpornografie. Weil wir zusätzlich auch noch mal noch mal einen kleinen Exkurs in die jüngste Gesetzgebung. Wir haben jetzt einen neuen Begriff, der heißt Kinder- und Jugendpornografie. Das sind also Abbildungen von Kindern, Jugendlichen in, sagt man, unnatürlicher sexueller Haltung. Wie ist die Formulierung da?
Ich komme mit Schwimmen. Mit geschlechtsbetonten.
Unnatürlich geschlechtsbetonter Haltung, genau. Sogenannte Posing-Fotos, die jetzt auch darunter fallen.
Fällt darunter eigentlich auch die Dr.Sommer-Seite in Abravo?
Das kommt drauf, als ob es dich erregt oder nicht, weil dann ist es Pornografie.
Aber es geht ja gar nicht darum, ob es dich erregt, sondern um die unnatürliche, ich habe schon wieder den Begriff vergessen, die unnatürliche Darstellung. Interessant ist natürlich auch, wie es mit vielen Kunstwerken ist. Also es gibt ja eine Geschichte der Kunst, gibt es eine ganze Menge Werke, zum Beispiel auch das Plattencover von Scorpions, die ja dann möglicherweise da drunter fallen. Und da wird sich jetzt zeigen, wie sich da die Rechtsprechung einpendelt. Es ist zum Beispiel gerade vor kurzem eine Verfassungsklage gegen diesen neuen Paragraph 184c Strafgesetzbuch eingereicht worden von Hassler, also eine große Erotikfirma. Und zwar hatten die ein Problem damit, dass sie ihre Teens, die zwar keine Teens sind, aber natürlich aus Marketingaspekten so genannt werden, nicht mehr so nennen dürfen oder dass sie befürchten, dass diese sogenannten Teens dann verboten sind. Weil nämlich auch Darstellungen, wo behauptet wird, das wären Minderjährige, auch unter diesen Paragraphen fallen. Also wir merken schon, da ist es tatsächlich ein ziemlich großes Feld. Was ist jetzt eigentlich Pornografie?
Auch schon wieder am Anfang der Sendung zum Thema Zensur im Internet, dass es so richtig gar kein rechtliches Korsett, keine rechtliche Grundlage dafür gibt. Also richtig Gesetze, die schon feststehen, das Ganze basiert. Und damit dann zurück zur Frage von Stefan. Wer bestimmt jetzt eigentlich wirklich diese Filterregeln?
Und was ich vielleicht noch dazugefügen wollte, die Frage ist ja dann auch noch, was passiert überhaupt, wenn wir erstmal überhaupt diese ganzen Sachen haben, diese ganze Technik, wenn hier erstmal alles am Start ist und so, und was wird dann als nächstes noch gefiltert? Das ist ja dann auch noch eine Frage, die dann an der ganzen Sache irgendwie noch mit anknüpft. Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass irgendwie, wenn jetzt gesagt wird, Kinderpornografie verboten, dann kommen jetzt die Nächsten und sagen, okay, die Neonazis wollen wir auch aus dem Netz haben. Und dann als nächstes wird irgendwie, was weiß ich, Firesharing oder sowas verboten. Und ich weiß nicht, wo wir denn da hinkommen, das mal ich mir irgendwie ganz böse aus. Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie anfangen zu filtern und so. Das ist so mein Grundsatz eigentlich. Aber ja.
Na ja, das ist wie bei den Mautbrücken. Die wurden ja auch aufgestellt mit der Ansage, dass das nur zu Abrechnungszwecken dient.
Und mittlerweile wären sie zu Verkehrsüberwachen genutzt?
Ja, genau. Das ist immer so eine Frage. Also wenn man Technik erschafft und dann kommen irgendwie Leute und haben ihre Begehrlichkeiten und dann sagt der wieder, ich will das und naja, dann haben wir nachher irgendwie einen Überwachungsstarter. Vorfürchte ich mich so ein bisschen.
Und genau das ist die Diskussion, die wir ja heute auch versuchen, hier ein bisschen abzubilden im Chaosradio.
Ja, ich hätte auch nochmal so eine Frage, um nochmal so ein bisschen ins Technische zurückzukommen. Entschuldigung, Jakob. Ich hätte mal eine Frage und zwar, wie sieht es denn aus mit I2P oder Freenet? Kann man sich damit irgendwie gut vor Zensur schützen? Also ich kann ja vielleicht so ein bisschen ausholen, dass es irgendwie der Ansatz ist, dass man quasi die Seiten nicht auf Server packt, sondern dass man das halt irgendwie...
Als Hidden Services? Sozusagen als Hidden Services?
Ja, das funktioniert dann so, dass man es halt nicht auf Server packt, sondern dass man es dezentral alles verwaltet und so. Ja, dass es dann auf die User verteilt. Das ist so ähnlich wie Peer-to-Peer. Ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich auch nicht ganz so viel Ahnung davon habe.
Das zeigt einen wichtigen Punkt. Also so Featermaßnahmen kann man natürlich immer besser machen, aber das Internet ist nun mal so gebaut, dass Dinge dezentral sind, dass Filter in irgendeiner Form nur begrenzt funktionieren können, weil man immer nur... Ja, also es ist quasi ein Katzen-Maus-Spiel. Habt man ja in der DNS-Geschichte gesehen, irgendwie sie filtern DNS, die Leute benutzen andere DNS-Server, jetzt müssen sie irgendwie mal ein bisschen tiefer und Proxys dazwischen schalten und so. Und das führt alles zunächst. Das ist ein technisches, ja noch nicht mal Wettrüsten, weil das zu umgehen wirklich, das kann man nicht als Rüsten bezeichnen, sondern das ist...
Es geht im Sand, also ich sehe da auch keine Lösung für. Also ich finde, da wird immer irgendwie wieder was sein, irgendjemand wird sich um was ausdenken und dann ist die ganze Filtergeschichte wieder für die Katz.
Zum Thema Filterregeln, Stefan, haben wir vielleicht jetzt einen Gesprächspartner, der da einiges Interessantes dazu sagen könnte. Der hat nämlich einen langen Artikel dazu geschrieben. Florian Walther vom Scusi-Blog. Du namen Florian. Hallo. Du hast solche Filterlisten analysiert. Kannst du vielleicht auf diese Frage, wer diese Filterregeln aufstellt und wie sie aussehen, eine genauere Antwort geben?
Nee, wer die aufstellt und wie die... also wer die aufstellt, darauf kann ich auch keine Antwort geben. Ich meine, in Deutschland sind die ja auch noch nicht in Place sozusagen. In den anderen Ländern, in denen sowas schon gibt, also in den Niederlanden, in Schweden, in Finnland, in Norwegen, in der Schweiz, da werden die meistens von zentralen Polizeidienststellen erstellt.
Wie auch das BKA.
Und in Deutschland ist ja auch in der Diskussion, dass es das BKA machen soll. Und die sagen ja auch, sie hätten schon eine Liste mit über 1000 Einträgen.
So, jetzt ist von Familienministerium und aber auch von den Behörden vom BKA heißt es immer, okay, da ist diese Pornografie, Kinderpornografie im Netz und wir kriegen die da nicht raus. So und jetzt, was machen wir? Wir kommen an diese Anbieter irgendwie nicht ran. Deswegen sperren wir das jetzt, weil das ist irgendwie das allerletzte Mittel, sagt auch die Frau von der Leyen. Es ist alles nicht schön, das wissen wir, aber wir wollen diesen Mist aus dem Netz haben. Wir wollen ihn nicht mehr sehen und wir wollen nicht mehr, dass die Leute da rankommen. Zumindest wollen wir es den Leuten, die da rankommen, wollen unbedingt ganz doll schwierig machen. Wir haben jetzt aber auch schon in der Sendung bisher gehört, das war eigentlich auch so, würde ich mal sagen, Condensed, dass alle gesagt haben, naja, also das Sperren, wegfiltern, das löst das Problem nicht wirklich. Sondern man müsste dann irgendwie Leute rangehen. Man sollte direkt auch in die Server ran und sollte schauen, dass man deren habhaft wird. Also nicht nur dem Server, sondern möglichst auch den Leuten, die die betreiben und die Kinderpornografie da vertreiben, verkaufen und damit möglicherweise sogar Geld verdienen. BKA ist wahrscheinlich dafür bei uns zuständig, wenn es um Sachen geht, die im Ausland stehen. Da gibt es eigentlich festgelegte Wege. Aber die Frage ist jetzt, ob die tatsächlich diese Wege auch beschritten werden. Also das heißt jetzt erstmal, ok, da ist eine Liste und die wollen wir jetzt sperren, weil wir kommen da nicht ran, wir kommen an dieses Server nicht ran. Wo stehen denn diese Server eigentlich? Oder was hast du jetzt gemacht, um herauszufinden, wo diese Server eigentlich stehen?
Naja, was ich gemacht hab, ist, ich hab mir im Internet Listen gesucht aus unseren europäischen Nachbarländern, die das schon machen, die mal veröffentlicht wurden, die von Aktivisten per Versuch, try and error, herausgefunden wurden. Also das Ding ist, sie sagen ja, sie wollen die Listen nicht veröffentlichen. Weil das wäre ja Werbung für die Seite. Aber man muss feststellen, dass wenn sie DNS-Sperren machen, dann veröffentlichen sie die Liste in dem Moment, wo sie die Sperren aktivieren. Das ist ähnlich wie beim Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Das Problem ist dann, man muss die richtigen Fragen stellen. Nämlich nach den richtigen Domainsfragen und mal klären, ob die IP-Adresse, die man als Antwort kriegt, noch die richtige ist.
Das heißt also, wenn ich nicht weiß, welche Seiten gesperrt sind, probiere ich einfach alle durch und die Seiten, die dann nicht wie erwartet ist anzeigen, sind möglicherweise gesperrt.
Ja, da kann man ja dann mal draufgehen auf die IP-Adresse, die man kriegt. Und wenn dann wie in Schweden so eine schöne Stoppseite von der Polizei kommt mit dem Hinweis, dass das illegal ist und so, dann hat man eine gesperrte Seite gefunden. Das heißt, man muss immer nur die richtigen Fragen stellen, aber die Listen müssen sie veröffentlichen, sonst können sie die Filter nicht implementieren. Zumindest auf DNS-Ebene ist das so.
Sind die DNS-Filter, von denen Andreas vorhin schon mal sprach?
Genau. Und ich habe jetzt mir Listen gesucht, die veröffentlicht wurden auf Wikileaks, haben Leute Listen veröffentlicht oder sind welche geleakt? Aus Dänemark glaube ich und aus Thailand. Es gibt Aktivisten in Schweden und in Finnland, die sich einen Spaß daraus gemacht haben, eben die richtigen Fragen an den DNS-Server zu stellen und solche Listen rauszufinden, einfach durchprobieren. Und genau die habe ich mir genommen, die man halt so findet. Und habe die einfach mal durch einen Perl-Script laufen lassen, was die Geolokationen der IP-Nummern rausfindet, auf welche diese Einträge zeigen.
Also sprich, wo sie stehen.
Ja genau, wo stehen die Server? Naja, und die Server stehen halt zum größten Teil in Juristikationen, in denen eine Verfolgung durchaus möglich wäre.
Ohne eine Wegsperrung der Seiten, sondern es ist anders, auf einem Weg möglich.
Naja klar, wenn so ein Server in den Niederlanden steht, ich meine das ist kein Problem. Wenn man bei den Niederländern anruft und sagt, hier Kinderpauno, die Adresse, der und der Server, steht bei euch, das ist der und der Anbieter, ich meine, dann geht's los, dann kriegen die da rapzap irgendwie einen Beschluss und fahren da hin und holen sich den Server zur forensischen Analyse. Also das wär zumindest, ja, so erstmal kein weiteres Problem. Und in Großbritannien, in Frankreich, in Spanien, in den USA, ich weiß nicht, ist das doch überall so? Ich meine, bei Kinderpauno sind sie sich doch einig, da klappt das doch mit der Rechtshilfe relativ gut.
Was ist so die Top 3 der Länder?
Ja, die Top 3 ist USA, Australien, Niederlande und auf Platz 4 Deutschland.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich so, dass das passiert. Es gibt Kooperationen der Provider untereinander, das In-Hope-Projekt, die Strafverfolgern zuarbeiten. Also ich hab auch mal diese Listen angeguckt, also insbesondere die aus Dänemark, die auf Wikileaks auch getaucht sind. Und vieles davon existiert einfach nicht mehr und das existiert ja mit einem bestimmten Grund nicht mehr, eben weil diese Strafverfolgung auch ein Stück weit funktioniert und diese Server werden beschlagnahmt.
Ja, aber wenn man, also das ist wahrscheinlich auch so, also ich hab die Liste dann auch nochmal bereinigt und Sachen, die geparkt sind und Sachen, die nicht auflösbar sind und so was rausgenommen. Also Dinge, die es nicht mehr gibt, dann bleiben auch nur noch 1500 Einträge von ursprünglich 6000 irgendwas übrig. Von ursprünglich 6021 bleiben da noch 1413. Und wenn man die nochmal durchjagt, na dann sind die Zahlen halt geringer, aber das Bild ist nicht ein anderes. Also die USA führen immer noch, gefolgt von Australien, gefolgt von Kanada. Niederlande auf Platz 4, Deutschland auf Platz 5.
Okay, aber welchen Schluss ziehen wir jetzt denn daraus, wenn es doch so relativ einfach ist, rauszukriegen, wo die Server stehen und dann mit den jetzt schon vorhandenen Mitteln der Strafverfolgung das anzugehen?
Ja, mein Schluss daraus ist ähnlich wie von Nicky aus Finnland, der auch sowas macht, der sich auch die Seiten zum Teil mal angeguckt hat und der halt wirklich Kinderpornografie mit unter 1% in den Adresslisten gefunden hat. Also es ist davon auszugehen oder es sieht so aus, dass auch in anderen Ländern eben nicht nur Kinderpornoseiten gesperrt werden, sondern die sind da relativ großzügig. Also eine Seite, die auf eine Kinderpornoseite linkt, wird auch mitgesperrt. Das sagen sie ja auch. Aber es sind halt auch viele Seiten dabei. Das ist halt Schwulenporn oder ich weiß nicht, sonst irgendwas, aber nichts, was jetzt wirklich illegal ist. Das einzigste, was die Seiten nicht machen, ist, sie haben nicht so eine Zugangssperre, wie es in Deutschland zum Beispiel vorgeschrieben ist, dass man halt da nur rankommt, wenn man 18 ist. Und das auch beweisen kann.
Würdest du so weit gehen zu sagen, dass dieses Gesetz, was jetzt möglicherweise in Kraft oder was jetzt diskutiert wird, dass das ein Schritt zur Zensur im Netz wird und liegt zur Nichtverfügungmachung von Inhalten?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall der Aufbau einer Zensurinfrastruktur, die einem diese Möglichkeiten bietet, Sachen zu unterbinden. Also ich meine, die Polizei ist sehr schlecht ausgestattet, klagt sie auch selber immer drüber. Und sie sagen ja auch, sie haben nicht genug Internetermittler und sie sind nicht kompetent genug, sie haben noch nicht mal genug Computer und so weiter und so fort. Und ich meine, das braucht man halt, wenn man da hinterher gehen will. Insofern ist das dann einfacher, weil das kann man einfach in eine Liste eintragen und dann ist gut.
Und dann gibt es nicht mehr alles weg.
Und da ist natürlich die Versuchung groß, irgendwie es auf die einfache Art und Weise zu lösen. Die Gefahr sehe ich zum einen. Die andere Gefahr, die ich sehe, ist, dass sie aufgrund von Personalmangel und sonst wie mangelnder technischer Kompetenz die Sachen automatisieren oder versuchen sie zu automatisieren.
Das Spannende ist ja auch die Stelle, an der gefiltert wird. Also einer der Grundsätze, die im CCC ab und zu mal wieder in den Mund genommen werden, ist, dass die Filterung findet im Endgerät statt. Also was mich besonders bedenklich gestimmt hat, ist eben, dass diese Zensurlisten nicht verfügbar gemacht werden zu Jugendschutzzwecken. Dass man eben sagen kann, wenn Eltern Sorge haben, dass die Kinder irgendwie im Internet komische Dinge sehen, dass man dann sich dieser Listen bedienen kann, sondern dass das quasi vom User unbeeinflussbar schon beim Internet Service Provider geschehen soll.
Und Programme, mit denen quasi Eltern den Rechner, also den heimatlichen Rechner, so bauen bzw. filtern können, dass ihre Sprösslinge nicht an bestimmte Webseiten rankommen. Da gibt es mehr als genug, zum Beispiel eine Menge sogar kostenlos. Fragtim, glaube ich, heißt eine. Das ist wo man irgendwie angeben kann, welche Webseiten es gibt. Also da gibt es eine ganze Menge und damit sind wir auch wieder bei der ganzen Verhältnismäßigkeit dieser Geschichte, die Alba vorher noch angesprochen hat.
Wobei es gibt ja immer noch diesen ganz komischen Ansatz, dass man sagt, alle Leute müssen sich auf ihrem PC eine Software installieren, die dann die Sachen wegfiltert.
Ja und porno im Internet erst nach 23 Uhr die Idee fand ich eigentlich nicht. Weil irgendwo auf der Welt ist es immer 23 Uhr. Und geht es dann nach, wo der Server steht oder wo der Client steht? Oder nimmt man ja...
Aber dann strich dir das alles nicht von der Grundannahme eines mündigen Bürgers aus, sondern davon, dass der Bürger vor irgendwas geschützt werden muss.
Um darauf zurückzukommen, ich sehe da noch weitere Probleme mit solchen Listen. In Finnland ist es zum Beispiel passiert, dass genau die Webseite, die diese Listen veröffentlicht hat, also wo der Aktivist da seine Sachen gepostet hat, dass die auch auf die Sperrliste gekommen ist. Also man hat dann die Leute, die die Zensur dokumentieren, auch gleich mit zensiert. Das war ihnen ein bisschen peinlich, das haben sie dann nach einer Woche auch wieder rückgängig gemacht, nachdem in der Zeitung zu lesen war, Polizei zensiert Zensurkritiker. Aber es zeigt, wo es hingehen kann. Und genau wenn man nicht genügend Ressourcen hat, ist die Versuchung natürlich groß für die Behörden, das zu automatisieren und sich darauf zu verlassen, was der Hersteller gesagt hat.
Womit wir zwei Sachen angesprochen hätten, die wichtig sind und die auch noch zu diskutieren sind. Zum einen natürlich, wer kontrolliert die Zensur? Also wer ist dafür zuständig, was das für Listen sind? Und zum zweiten, das was Nübler eben auch angesprochen hat, die Filterung findet im Endgerät statt. Also dass unterm Strich jeder User, jeder Internetbenutzer sein eigener Filter ist und selbst quasi die Hoheit der demokratischen Entscheidung hat zu sagen, das will ich im Netz sehen und das will ich im Netz nicht sehen und das gucke ich mir nicht an. Und sollte der Rechner von mehreren Leuten benutzt werden, da auch ein Mitspracherecht hat.
Die Freiheit und Möglichkeit hat ja jeder heutzutage schon und viele Leute benden sich ja Werbeanzeigen auch aus auf ihren Internetseiten oder in ihren Browsern.
Genau, dazu fragen wir gleich mal jemanden, der junger Vater ist, der mehrere Kinder auch zu Hause hat. Florian, ich wollte noch ganz kurz die Adresse von deinem Blog sagen. Damit die Leute auch noch mal nachlesen können. Das ist scusi.blog.org, scusi mit C. Und da ist das alles noch mal nachzulesen jetzt, Frank.
Entschuldigung, nee, auch noch mal ganz kurz dein Fazit sozusagen. Also wenn aus der Politik behauptet wird, wir kommen an diese Server nicht ran, kannst du sagen, Quatsch, also ich hab hier die Zahlen, wäre alles möglich, zumindestens in einer Großzahl der Fälle.
Naja, mein Problem ist, ich hab die ja im Prinzip ja, aber ich hab keine aktuellen Listen. Und wenn man mir die aktuelle Liste gibt, kann ich das auf jeden Fall. Aber ich unterschreib keinen NDA dafür. Und ansonsten werde ich, sobald diese Listen aktiv sind, versuchen sie rauszufinden. Und da bin ich guter Dinge, dass ich das schaffe und dann werde ich sie auch posten. Ich meine, ich habe ja nur die richtigen Fragen gestellt.
Aber das wäre jetzt auch eine ganz klare Forderung an die Politik, zu sagen, du weißt erst mal, dass ihr wirklich versucht habt, an diese Dinge heranzukommen.
Man tut erst mal alles Mögliche, was man technisch, menschlich, kriminalistisch, forensisch, weiß ich nicht, tun kann, um an die Hintermänner heranzukommen. Folgt den Finanzströmen irgendwie. Also zieht die Leute aus dem Verkehr, die das Zeug herstellen und die daran verdienen. Und die Seiten auszublenden ist keine Lösung. Und das schützt auch kein Kind vor irgendeinem Missbrauch. Ein Kind vor Missbrauch schützen, wie die Frau Leiden vorgibt, zu tun, kann sie erst, wenn sie wirklich so einen Typen einsperrt, der sowas gemacht hat und wo die Chance, dass er es wieder macht, irgendwie gegeben ist.
Sagt Florian Walter von scusiblog.org. Danke dir Florian. Oh, da war ein radikaler Hörer aufgeschmissen.
Das war jetzt alles okay. Einen Einwurf habe ich aber noch an der Stelle. Und zwar, Wegsperren hilft nicht nur, weil das hilft erst, wenn es schon zu spät ist, wenn der Missbrauch schon passiert ist. Therapie hilft. Und es gibt in Berlin ein einzigartiges Pilotprojekt in Deutschland. Eine Therapiestelle für Pädophile. Also Leute, die das Problem haben, so ey Scheiße, ich stehe auf Kinder. Was mache ich denn jetzt? Hingehen können, sich damit beschäftigen können und irgendwie da Lösungen angeboten bekommen. Und ich denke, das ist viel, viel hilfreicher als irgendwelche Filter, irgendwelche Sperrlisten tatsächlich Missbrauch zu verhindern.
Und die sind da auch sehr unverkrampft auf die Leute mit diesen Problemen zugegangen. Mit Pustern, auf denen eben die Frage gestellt wurde, mögen sie Kinder mehr als ihnen lieb ist. Also es ist ja wahrscheinlich das erste Mal, dass jemand, der mit diesen Problemen konfrontiert wird, nicht sich dafür vor der Gesellschaft irgendwie schämen und in die Ecke und überhaupt, sondern ihm geholfen wird, damit in irgendeiner Form umzugehen, wie es für die Gesellschaft nicht zum Problem wird.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, Nummer 142 mittlerweile schon. Es geht um Zensur am Internet, die angedacht wird vom Bundesfamilienministerium. Und wir haben Chris am Telefon. Guten Abend Chris, grüß dich. Hast du gehört, was Frank eben gerade alles erzählt hat? Was ist denn deine Meinung dazu?
Ja, wie gesagt, also dieses Wagnungs von der Charité sogar wurde zu kurz ausgestrahlt, man sollte einfach mehr dahinter sein. Und die Politik sollte einfach mal, oder die Justiz und Politik, also die Justiz von der Politik sollte einfach mehr, ja, sollten mehr Strafen, die sollten einfach mehr Gesetze dafür rausbringen. Und gerade sich damit mehr befassen. Die reden alle von wegen, ja, Kinderschutzbund und sonstiges, aber irgendwie bleibt das auf der Strecke.
Aber du meinst jetzt, du willst mehr Gesetze machen. Das heißt, du meinst, die Gesetze, die wir jetzt haben, reichen nicht aus?
Die sollten verschärft werden. Das reicht nicht aus. Kein Fall. Und das stimmt schon. Also hier irgendwelche Dinge zu spüren, hilft auch nicht. Ich mein, der Missbrauch bleibt trotzdem. Ich find's sowieso krass. Also ich bin wie gesagt Vater. Und wenn ich daran denke, dann wird mir schlecht.
Wie ist das bei euch zu Hause? Wenn du sagst, du bist Vater, hast also auch Kinder, gibt es da so feste Regeln, wonach du sagst, hier an dem Rechner werden nur von dann und dann im Netz gesurft?
Also ich hab meinen PC so eingerichtet, dass er gar nicht auf andere Seiten kommen kann.
Bei dem CCT-Grundsatz, den Nibbler eben vorhin sagte, der letzte Filter oder eigentliche Filter sitzt immer noch davor. Aber was hältst du von der Verhältnismäßigkeit, die geplant wurde, also Webseiten wegzusperren?
Wenn sie es auch machen, also reden bringt nichts.
Das Gesetz ist jetzt in der Diskussion. Es soll, wenn ich das richtig mitgekriegt habe, irgendwie im Laufe dieses Jahres in der Änderung vom Medien... Andreas, hilf mir mal. Das Gesetz heißt das Medien... Telemediengesetz. Da soll es eine Änderung geben dieses Jahr. Da wird noch einiges passieren. Wir haben ja auch Wahljahr. Wahrscheinlich wird sich da noch einiges tun. Aber danke dir erstmal für den Anruf, Chris. 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über den Vorstoß vom Bundesfamilienministerium von Frau von der Leyen, die sich Anfang des Monats mit deutschen Provider getroffen hat, mit verschiedenen, um bestimmte Webseiten wegzusperren. Wir versuchen zu klären, wie das technisch eigentlich funktioniert und sind immer noch bei der bislang ungeklärten Frage, dass es eigentlich keine sowohl juristische als auch moralische Grundstruktur gibt, wonach diese Sperrung und Filterung eigentlich passieren kann. Es wurde immer der Vorschuss gemacht, wir müssen das alles verbieten, aber keiner weiß auf welcher Grundlage sowas passieren soll, Frank.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen schwierig, weil man muss das dann mal ein bisschen aufrollen oder nach hinten weiterspinnen, je nachdem von welcher Seite man es betrachtet. Wenn ich jetzt Internet-User bin, ich habe einen Vertrag mit meinem Internetprovider, und dieser Internetprovider zeigt mir jetzt bestimmte Sachen nicht an. Das heißt also, aus meiner Sicht erbringt er dann erstmal eine bestimmte Dienstleistung nicht ordnungsgemäß. Dann muss ich ja auch eine Möglichkeit haben als Kunde zu sagen, bitte lieber Internetprovider, du erbringst ja deine Dienstleistung nicht richtig. Dann muss der Provider natürlich sagen, ja aber ich mach das doch, weil ich bin zum Beispiel per Gesetz verpflichtet diese Seiten rauszufiltern. Oder so wie es jetzt im Moment ist, steht der Internetprovider relativ blöd da. Und kann halt wissen sagen, hey du Ferkel, du wolltest hier Kinderpornografie klicken, gibt es bei uns nicht, geh zu einem anderen Provider. Oder er sagt halt, naja, wir haben da mit der Ministerin mal irgendwie einen Tee getrunken und die hat uns eine Liste gegeben und die sperren wir jetzt. Das ist die Situation, die wir jetzt haben. Und die ist natürlich für einen Internetprovider auch nicht wirklich zufriedenstellend. Weil er weiß ja oder müsste eigentlich diese Liste immer kontrollieren und dann nochmal pro Eintrag, der da drauf ist, schauen, ob er das dann wirklich auch sperren will. Und müsste sich der Sache eigentlich auch wieder setzen. Und das ist natürlich dann auch wieder eine schwierige Situation, wenn jetzt der Provider anfangen muss, nochmal wirklich diese Liste zu prüfen, ob denn da wirklich auch tatsächlich echt strafbare Inhalte drin sind.
Das ist natürlich auch eine PR-Frage. Also gerade das Thema Kinderpornos sehr emotional beladen. Und als ISP, das große ISP, wenn man dann auch nicht dastehen und sich von der Familienministerin sagen lassen, ja, alle haben mitgemacht, aber die Bude da nicht, das sind ganz böse Leute und die verbreiten Verbreitung von Kinderpornos. Da ist natürlich auch bei den ISPs so ein bisschen die Angst, dass dann damit der Keule gekommen wird.
Ja, andererseits ist es so, wenn dann auch möglicherweise mehr Sachen gesperrt werden. Also ich meine, es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen negatives Marketingargument, wenn man sagt, naja, bei dem Provider kann man kein Porno klicken. Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das durchaus auch eine gewisse Anzahl von Kunden abschreckt.
Oder um einfach mal jetzt auch von dieser Porno-Kiste wegzukommen, da kann man halt keine Musik aus dem Netz laden. Du kannst keine Musik aus dem Netz laden, oder? Aber was es in Hessen gab, den Vorschlag aus Hessen, der im letzten Dezember, also letzten Monat kam, dass die sagten, so internationale Lotterie-Seiten, die es im Netz gibt, die hätten wir gerne auch nicht mehr. Und vielleicht können die auch gleich mit weggeschaltet werden.
Dann Chemikalienversand wird weggefiltert. Kommst du vom 100.
ins 1000. Und da diese Listen nicht öffentlich sind, da diese Listen nicht einsehbar sind und bislang immer noch nicht klar ist, wer quasi die Zensoren kontrolliert, was da passiert, wird dann eine Büchse der Pandora aufgemacht, von der keiner weiß, was da im Endeffekt wirklich das Resultat ist, was dabei rauskommt.
So ein schönes Argument, was man von Internetausdruckern hört, das Internet ist kein rechtsfreier Raum.
Der Internetausdrucker ist toll.
Wer behauptet, dass das Internet kein rechtsfreier Raum ist, hat noch nicht verstanden, dass das Internet gar kein Raum ist.
Sondern?
Das war jetzt auch ein schönes Gegenargument. Da musst du noch ein bisschen weiter argumentieren, Snibbler.
Es ist ein Netz.
Sachen sind nur dann im Internet illegal, wenn sie ohne Internet auch illegal sind.
Musik.
In dem so ist, dann ist es okay, Musik. Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 142 am 28. Januar 2009. Wir reden über Zensur im Internet, das Internet soll sauber werden, ein Familieninternet werden gefiltert mit verbotenen Inhalten, also mit Inhalten, die verboten werden und zensiert. Eure Meinung dazu unter 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sattarj aus Berlin. Guten Abend Sattarj, grüß dich. Was hältst du denn von dieser angedachten Zensur von bestimmten Webseiten, von der keiner noch so richtig weiß, a. auf welcher rechtlichen Grundlage es steht und b. wo es hinführt?
Also, ich finde es schon mal gut, dass man sich darüber erstmal einen Kopf macht, wie man das wegkriegt. Aber die Seiten einfach filtern bringt nicht wirklich viel, weil erstens würden die nie im Leben, würde der Staat oder die, die das machen, würden nie neben alle Seiten rausfinden. Das heißt, irgendwo gibt es immer die Seiten. Und die Leute einfach, wenn man die Seiten einfach sperrt, würde man sich einfach neu schaffen, wo der auch schon gesagt, und was jetzt auch das Problem ist, die Leute, also die Menschen sind einfach so, wenn irgendwas nicht gesättigt ist, gibt es denen halt, also die meisten, halt einen Kick sozusagen. Also, dass sie das halt weitermachen, dass es denen halt mehr Spaß macht, wobei es halt nämlich gesättigt ist. Und damit kann man sich nicht wirklich verhindern. Also so wird es einfach mit den Seiten filtern.
Also da muss ich jetzt mal die, mal eine Argumentation vom Ministerium anbringen. Dass sie sagen, ja, also wenn die Anbieter sich dann aber eine neue Adresse suchen, dann sind sie ja auch erstmal nicht auffindbar, so ohne Freiheit. Also dann sind sie quasi erstmal, dann ist die übliche Quelle ist dann weg. Ich muss mir denn wieder was Neues suchen. Und damit ist möglicherweise schon ein Ziel auch wieder erreicht.
Hält einen aber nicht davon auf, davon ab, diese URL per E-Mail oder auf irgendeinem anderen Weg zu distributen?
Klar, man muss es dann aber erstmal wieder bekommen. Aber ich sag mal, der übliche, also das ist halt so, als wenn mein Zeitungsladen an der Ecke zumacht, so dann muss ich mir halt erstmal einen anderen suchen. Zumindest für ein paar Tage habe ich dann möglicherweise keine Zeitung zu Hause.
Die Argumentation an sich ist klar und auch logisch, je höher du die Hürde legst, um irgendwas ranzukommen, desto schwieriger wird es, dass Leute das finden. Soweit so gut und soweit auch so richtig. Aber die Gefahren bzw. die Abas und die ungeklärten Punkte, die da hinten dranhängen, die tauchen eben nicht in dieser Argumentation auf. Die zum Beispiel beinhalten, was ist, wenn es andere Befindlichkeiten gibt von Leuten, die sagen, wir hätten sowas gerne nicht mehr im Netz, wie Musikindustrie, wie Lottogesellschaften und sonst was. Das ist ja alles noch nicht geklärt.
Ja, also ich bin auch konkret gegen Pornografie. Und wenn du kurzestern kurz aus der Wohnung raus... Ich muss leise sein, die schlafen alle. Da hat mich ein langer Moment.
Ja, wir wollen ja keinen wecken. Wobei, wenn ihr jetzt hier einschlaft, verpasst ihr noch eine Menge.
Aber sag mal ganz kurz, du hast gesagt, gegen Pornografie, meinst du jetzt gegen Kinder, also Missbrauchsdarstellung von Kindern? Oder generell gegen Pornografie?
Also gegen Pornografie, jetzt allgemein habe ich ein Geschenk, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so was macht, so gegen Kinderpornografie. Dagegen bin ich total, ich habe selber ein Kind, das jetzt zwei Jahre alt ist. Wenn mein Kind später aus seinen Seiten gehen würde, ich weiß nicht, auf was für Gedanken er kommen würde. Ich würde das für mein Kind einfach nicht anfinden. Bei mir hat zum Beispiel mein Rechner, auch wenn wir ganz oft bekannte, und ich schlafe auch ganz viel mit den Kindern da. Wir haben fünf Computer zu Hause. Ich habe mir selber am Programm geschrieben. Wo der kontrolliert, was für Seiten sind, und wenn das eine pornografische Seite ist, wird sie sofort gesperrt. Also, dass schon gar nichts mehr drauf kann. Und wenn es halt eine porno-Date ist...
Von welchen Kriterien?
Wie von welchen Kriterien?
Na, wie stellt deine Software fest, das ist porno oder das ist kein porno?
Na, in dem Moment, wenn man auf so eine Seite rausgeht, kriegt man ja auch Videos an, normalerweise. Also man ist ja nicht so da, um die Bilder, sich von den Videos anzugucken, die Startbilder. Und in dem Moment merkt man ja, merkt meine Software, mein Programm, dass es ein porno-Set ist und sperrt die dann halt sofort. Weil ich nicht will, dass Kinder so was schon in so einem Jahr mitkriegen.
Womit wir bei der Anfangsdiskussion sind, dass im Endeffekt auch die Eltern bzw. die Leute, die mit Kindern zusammenleben, größere Geschwister, wer auch immer, dafür auch in die Verantwortung zu nehmen sind, mitzugucken, was da im Netz und auf dem Rechner zu sehen ist oder nicht. Danke für deine Aufmerksamkeit, wir müssen jetzt die Nachrichten machen. Ja, schönen Abend und wieder leise in die Wohnung, sonst wächst ihr alle auf.
Na, Deutschlands größter Musikpreis?
Jetzt präsentiert, Echo, Echo, Valhalla, Echo 2009, live in Berlin und im ersten, mit Amy McDonald, Katy Perry, you too und vielen, vielen, vielen mehr. Samstag, 21. Februar in der Echo Two World Berlin.
Natürlich im Fritz-Echo-Radio.
Die Echo-Verleihung 2009 in Berlin. Live im ersten deutschen Fernsehen.
Und im letzten deutschen Radio.
Und das war's. Nachrichten.
Mit Kaitern Dürlich.
Der Vorsitzende des Landeselternausschüsse Schindler fordert zusätzliche Anreize für Nachwuchslehrer. Damit sollen angehende Lehrer an den Berliner Schulen gehalten werden. Berlin müsse die jungen Pädagogen besser vergüten, sagte Schindler. Er ist aber gegen eine generelle Verbeamtung von Lehrern. Mehr als 100 junge Pädagogen hatten zuvor angekündigt, sich in anderen Bundesländern zu bewerben. Dort würden sie besser bezahlt werden und die Chance haben, verbeamtet zu werden. Wer morgen mit dem Zug fahren will, sollte sich auf Behinderung einstellen. In insgesamt neun Städten wollen morgen früh Bahnmitarbeiter streiken. Auch Berlin ist davon betroffen. S- und U-Bahn sowie Busse werden aber normal fahren. Die Gewerkschaften Transnet und GDBA haben angekündigt, dass bis in den späten Vormittag hineingestreikt werden soll und dass deswegen Züge zu spät kommen oder sogar ausfallen werden. Mit dem Streik soll Druck im Tarifstreit gemacht werden, bei dem es laut den Gewerkschaften nicht vorangeht. Im Zeichen der internationalen Finanz- und Wirtschaftskrise hat in Davos das Weltwirtschaftsforum begonnen. Bei der Eröffnung warnte der russische Minister Präsident Putin vor zu starken Eingriffen des Staates in die Wirtschaft. Dabei hat er auf Erfahrung in der Sowjetunion hingewiesen. Bis zum Sonntag tauschen sich beim Weltwirtschaftsforum 2500 Persönlichkeiten aus Politik und Wirtschaft über die aktuellen Entwicklungen aus. Energie Cottbus ist im Achtelfinale des DFB Pokals ausgeschieden. Cottbus unterlag Leverkusen mit 1 zu 3. Außerdem spielten Dortmund Bremen 1 zu 2, Wolfsburg Rostock 5 zu 1 und Karlsruhe Wien Wiesbaden 0 zu 1. Überschattet wurde das Achtelfinale von einem tragischen Zwischenfall in Dortmund. Ein Fan stürzte kurz vor dem Spiel von der Südtribüne und erlitt tödliche Verletzungen. Die Ursache für den Sturz sind bisher noch nicht geklärt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Cottbus, Frankfurt, Neurupien, Wittenberge und Angermünde da haben wir minus 4 Grad, Potsdam minus 3 und in Berlin da haben wir zwischen minus 3 und minus 4 Grad. In dieser Nacht geht es mit den Temperaturen immer weiter runter mit Tieswerten zwischen minus 1 und minus 5 Grad. Dazu haben wir viel Nebel und auch der Rest der Woche bleibt nebelig und trüb. Nachts bleibt es meist frostig, tagsüber wird es aber meistens trocken bleiben. Morgen haben wir dann Temperaturen von maximal plus 2 Grad. Wir haben eine Meldung aus Brandenburg auf der A115 Abus Zubringer Nutetal statt auswärts zwischen Kreuz Zehlendorf und Kleinmachno. Da befinden sich Wildschweine auf der Fahrbahn. Fahr dort bitte besonders vorsichtig, ansonsten eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn im Radio 101, 5?
Dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Da war das Mikro noch offen, aber das heißt wir sind auch da. Chaosradio 142 auf Fritz. Frage ist hier, Nibbler ist da, Andreas ist da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, Chaos Computer Club begrüßt euch. Wir diskutieren über die angesetzte und angeplante Zensur und Filterung im Internet, die von der Bundesfamilienministerin Frau von der Leyen ja im Moment angeschoben wird. Wir hatten vorhin ganz kurz das Thema Filter gestreift, eben gerade als Zertasch auch nochmal gesagt, dass der Rechner bei ihm zu Hause auch mit einer Art Filter funktioniert, woraufhin Nibbler mehr oder weniger noch dazwischen ging und sagte, ja so genau kann der Filter gar nicht gehen. Das müssen wir jetzt nochmal in Ruhe klären. Also wir hatten vorhin die DNS-Filter, die in skandinavischen Ländern funktionieren, die aber nicht die Filter sind, die hier eingesetzt werden sollen, oder?
Ja, da ist ein bisschen unklar, was wir als Filter einsetzen, aber ich gehe mal von aus, dass das nicht bei DNS-Filtern bleiben wird, weil inzwischen, glaube ich, dithinreichend bekannt sein dürfte, wie man das Ganze umgeht und anderen DNS-Server eintragen und weitersurfen. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das anspruchsvoller wird.
Also ist dieses DNS-Filtersystem überhaupt keine Option für hier?
Also nochmal ganz kurz, DNS, also Domain Name Service, dafür steht hier Abkürzung, ist also der Dienst im Internet, der den Namen von der Webseite in die numerische IP-Adresse, also die eigentliche Internetadresse umwandelt. Und was bei dieser DNS-Sperre gemacht wird, ist, dass dieser Name dann nicht zu der richtigen IP-Adresse aufgelöst wird, sondern zu einer anderen oder gar nicht aufgelöst wird. Und damit wird also sozusagen nicht die eigentliche Verbindung zu der Webseite gekappt, sondern sie wird nur nicht richtig gefunden.
Das heißt, wer du weißt, wo du suchen musst, findest du es trotzdem?
Genau, wenn man sich also schafft, den Weg, diese IP-Adresse von der eigentlichen Webseite zu besorgen, indem man zum Beispiel einfach nicht den DNS-Server, also diesen Namensauflösungsdienst fragt, den mir mein Provider anbietet, sondern ich mir einen eigenen baue, das geht ja. Es gibt also die großen, diese sogenannten Root-Server, die im Internet stehen, die also eine Datenbank haben von allen, die so die Autorität sind des Netzes. Mein Internet-Provider, der bietet mir diesen DNS an, diesen Server, den ich dann anfrage. Der macht das einfach, damit nicht jeder kleine Popelrechner irgendwie diese großen Root-Nameserver, die im Internet irgendwo stehen, anfragt, sondern das ist wie so ein Proxy, also ein Stellvertreter. Das heißt also, ich frag den an und der fragt dann, wenn das nicht eh schon weiß, die IP-Adresse, dann den nächstgelegenen an. Und was ich dann einfach mache, wenn ich so eine DNS-Sperre umgehen will, ist, dass ich mir einfach irgendeinen anderen DNS-Server suche, der diese Sperre nicht eingebaut hat, der kann irgendwo in einem anderen Land stehen. Das kann aber auch ein eigener sein, den ich mir irgendwie gesucht hab oder der von irgendjemand anders betrieben wird.
Und wie soll das jetzt rein technisch funktionieren, mit diesen Filtern, die angedacht werden?
Also was ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen könnte... Da müssen wir mal kurz einen Exkurs machen, wie dieses Internet eigentlich zusammenhängt. Die Provider sprechen untereinander das Border Gateway Protocol, also BGP. Das ist ein Protokoll, mit dem ausgetauscht wird, welche IP-Adressen sich wo befinden. Also ich krieg von meinem Internetprovider beispielsweise als Internet... Also wenn ich selbst einen Internetprovider bin und mit anderen Traffic austausche, bekomme ich jeweils den Satz IP-Adressen, die Netze, die hinter dem Provider liegen und kann dann selbst entscheiden, was sich in welche Richtung rute. Ja, so ist das Internet quasi als Flickenteppich zusammengeklebt. Jeder tauscht mit jedem auf einer bestimmten Basis seine Routen aus. Und da, schätze ich mal, werden sie ansetzen, dass man also nicht ganze Netze jetzt filtert und austauscht. Sondern, dass man einzelne IP-Adressen hat, die in irgendeiner Form bösen Content enthalten. Und die quasi beim Internet-Service-Provider aus dem Routing nimmt, über einen Proxy leitet, URLs ausfiltert und das Ganze weitergibt. Je nachdem, wie viel Traffic man hat, ist das dann entweder ein Proxy oder eine kompliziertere Filter-Einrichtung, die speziell sich Pakete anguckt, ansonsten alles vorwortet. Aber wenn eine bestimmte URL drin vorkommt, die Verbindung zurücksetzt oder anderen Content einbaut, das ist mittlerweile technisch quasi problemlos möglich.
Ganz kurz gefragt, also ich kenne natürlich die Antwort, aber nochmal für die Hörer, warum sperrt man nicht eine einzelne IP-Adresse einfach?
Weil auf einer IP-Adresse, Beispiel Geocities oder irgendwelche Free-Hoster, wo man auf einem Server ganz viele Websites liegen hat, wenn man da eine einzelne IP sperren würde, gäbe das einfach zu viel Kollateralschaden.
Das heißt, du sperrst eine IP-Adresse und haust alle anderen gleich mit weg?
Ja, und das ist natürlich etwas, was den Usern auch nicht gefällt. Den Usern ist es wahrscheinlich ziemlich egal, ob da jetzt Kinder-Porno gefiltert wird oder nicht. Aber wenn noch mehr nicht geht, dann fällt das zum einen rüber auf und zum anderen geht es am Ziel vorbei.
Aber wäre das nicht ein Druckmittel gegen den Serverbetreiber? Wenn du irgendwo auf deinem Server Kinder-Pornografie hast, entsperren wir dir einfach den Server?
Ja, aber das geht viel zu sehr wieder in Richtung Strafverfolgung. Und das ist ja scheinbar das, was gerade nicht hip ist. Also wenn es um Strafverfolgung ginge, würden sie ja gleich zu den Serverbetreibern hingehen und die unter Druck setzen. Das scheint ja wohl nicht so das Problem zu sein.
Weil, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, ist es relativ einfach nachzuvollziehen, wo die Server stehen.
Das passiert ja auch schon. Also wenn tatsächlich Serverbetreiber verhaftet, die sollte es Material anbieten. Es gibt Server, die sind nicht mehr da, einfach aus genau diesem Grund.
Okay, also wir fassen nochmal ganz kurz zusammen. Die Server sind relativ einfach zu finden, mit normalen Mitteln der Strafverfolgung. Das heißt, du kannst die Leute auch an Arsch kriegen, wenn du das denn möchtest. Und jetzt kommt Robert ins Spiel. Robert hat angerufen mit einer großartigen Frage. Guten Abend, Robert. Grüße dich. Stell die Frage selber, weil ich möchte nochmal lachen.
Als absoluter Grund-User. Also meine Kompetenz und mein Horizont, was Internet und Nutzung angeht, ist recht beengst. Ich weiß, wie ein Internet-Experte funktioniert, aber dann hört es auch schon fast auf. Und genau das gleich würde ich auch der Politik unterstellen, wie jetzt von den Personen wie Frau von der Leyen, die sich dann heransetzen und sagen, ja, Photografie ist scheiße, ist scheiße, definitiv. Mensch, das können wir noch sperren. Aber ich frage mich, ob das nicht eine Spirale ist. Was ja schon genannt wurde, war, gut, okay, sperre eine Seite, ja, dann mach ich halt eine neue auf. Ich lenke da vielleicht ein paar Tage voll ab, aber komm dann doch wieder auf den Trichter. Ich will das irgendwie mit Viren oder Toyala vergleichen. Trotz alledem ist mir nie davor gefeilt, dass sich doch irgendjemand dieser Spirale wieder setzt oder sie überlistet und mein Rechner doch auch spioniert oder was auch immer.
Aber es gibt doch auch noch die Frage hier an die Kollegen von CCC, wenn solche Gesetze geplant werden, ausgedacht werden und so, es gibt doch da auch Fachleute, die da durchaus auch ihre fachliche Meinung dazu geben und sagen, wird so nicht funktionieren oder sehe ich das zu naiv?
Also ich kann ja auch mal ein bisschen plaudern, nicht zu sehr, aber es gibt immer das Argument der Provider, naja es sind zu große Datenmengen. Und es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die Geräte dafür jetzt da sind. Und zumindest in Deutschland müssen solche Geräte, die den Netzwerkverkehr überwachen, die den Netzwerk steuern können, müssen auch angeschafft werden, um bestimmte gesetzliche Auflagen zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung anzuschaffen.
Stichwort Trafikausleitung. Also wenn man irgendwie als ISP die Anfrage bekommt, wir hätten gerne den ganzen Traffic von dem User oder E-Mails von dem User, dann wird er einfach auf diese Hardware gehängt. Und das muss einfach mal funktionieren. Es ist da, es ist Infrastruktur, die existiert, die deploit ist, die man natürlich auch zu anderen Dingen verwenden kann. ISPs machen das in der Regel auch, um mit den Trafficmengen umzugehen, um den Usern trotzdem eine gute Servicequalität zu bieten, um ihnen problemlos nicht drogelndes Voice-over-IP beispielsweise zu geben, während sie gerade mit HTTP oder anderen Dingen ihre Leitungen breit dicht machen wurden.
Um nochmal zurückzukommen und Robert mit ins Boot zu holen, er sagt, er ist Grunduser, was ich sehr sympathisch finde. Ich glaube, ein Tenor oder eine Grundmeinung der Sendung, die jetzt knapp eine Dreiviertelstunde läuft, ist, dass viele Leute sagen, es steht keinerlei Verhältnismäßigkeit zu dem, was sie eigentlich erreichen wollen. Nun gibt es dieses Gesetz, also den Gesetzentwurf, der wird gerade diskutiert und es kann sein, dass es dieses Jahr in irgendeiner Form durchgeht. Hat der Grunduser, wie Robert oder Icke oder wer auch immer gerade zuhört, irgendjemand die Chance zu sagen, ich möchte das nicht, ich glaube, das geht in eine falsche Richtung, kann ich mich irgendwie dazu äußern, außer hier in dieser Sendung oder in einem Webblog?
Das Problem ist, dass es ein sehr heikles Thema ist und dass eine Diskussion darüber dann auch schnell sehr emotional, teilweise auch mit ziemlich widerlichen Argumenten geführt wird. Es gibt wenig Leute, die sich einfach trauen, in die Öffentlichkeit zu stellen und sagen, Kinderpornografie fehltern ist blöd, ist schlecht. Da ist man automatisch erstmal Außenseiter. Das macht die Diskussion darüber auch ziemlich schwierig. Vielleicht braucht Frau von der Leyen auch noch ganz viele Briefe von Internet-Usern, auch von nicht Experten, sondern die auch ruhig ein bisschen naiv sind, sagen, aber Frau von der Leyen, glauben Sie wirklich, dass das was bringt? Sie machen unser Internet kaputt. Vielleicht hilft sowas, wenn sie da viele Briefe kriegt, möglicherweise.
Ist das eine Argumentationslinie, mit der du leben kannst, Robert?
Nein, also sicherlich finde ich es gut, wenn sich Frau von der Leyen mit sowas beschäftigen würde, auch mit kritischen Äußerungen von Usern. Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass es zum einen zeitlich gerade nicht schafft, weil sie sich um ihre sieben Kinder kümmern muss, und zum anderen glaube ich auch nicht selbst, wenn jetzt dieses Verbot in irgendeiner Form eingekippt wird. Das Internet ist für mich ein grenzenloses Netz. Das bedeutet, wenn irgendjemand irgendwelche Inhalte haben möchte, dann wird er sie auch bekommen. Da bin ich mir zu 100 Prozent sicher. Genau, ganz genau, das ist der Fakt. Es ist wie so ein Kleinuniversum. Ich glaube nicht, dass mit was für einem Aufwand auch immer die in der Lage sind, die zu 50, 60, 70 Prozent so zu sichern, für sich selber, also aus ihrer Sicht, dass solche Pseudo-Seiten, wo sie jetzt der Meinung sind, dass denen die kritisch nicht an den Enduser geraten. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Gut, aber da muss ich ja noch mal einhaken. Das ist ja auch die Argumentation vom Ministerium, dass er sagt, wir wollen ja gar nicht alles blockieren, wir wollen ja gar nicht perfekt sein, wir wollen einfach nur ein paar Prozent sperren. Das ist ein ganz einfaches Mittel, da gibt es diese Listen, die werden in die Provider geschickt und es reicht uns, wenn wir ein paar Prozent davon abhalten, diese Sachen anzuschauen und dafür auch kein Geld fließen kann. Und dann haben wir das Ziel schon erreicht.
Aber das Gegenargument, was genau an dieser Stelle kommt, wäre doch zu sagen, damit wird aber das eigentliche Problem gar nicht erkannt, bekämpft und bearbeitet, sondern es passiert nichts mehr. Außer einer quasi einer Pseudo.
Genau, man kann sich denn zurücklehnen und sagen, wir haben was gemacht.
Wir haben was gemacht. Natürlich kann es nicht perfekt sein, aber wir haben uns da reingehängt.
Genau, das ist ja das, was gerade passiert und was wir jetzt auch seit anderthalb Stunden hier kritisieren. Und ihr auch.
Robert, danke dir für den Anruf. Nächster am Telefon ist Niklas, der musste auch schon ganz schön lange warten. Hallo Niklas, guten Abend. Ich hoffe, du bist nicht sauer, dass du hier ein bisschen in der Leitung gehangen hast. Alles klar. Wie stehst du zu der Thematik Zensur im Internet?
Ja, also was ich noch anmerken wollte, was ich für die eigentliche Gefahr halte, ist, dass man so ein Stückchen das Vertrauen ins Internet insgesamt verliert. Also es gibt natürlich noch viele andere Gründe, warum man nicht allem trauen sollte, was man im Internet liest. Aber ich hatte da vor kurzem so ein Beispiel. Ich habe von eurem Kollegen Tim den Podcast gehört über diesen DECT Hack und wollte auch mal auf dieser Seite, dected.org, vorbeischauen, wo es die ganzen Papers gibt und die Software und so weiter. Und die war irgendwie vorletzte Woche schlecht erreichbar. Also ich habe es mehrmals versucht. Das ging dann gar nicht. Oder es gab auch irgendwelche obskuren SSL-Fehlermeldungen.
Die war wahrscheinlich schwer gefragt, die Seite.
Ja, das ist natürlich die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung erstmal. Aber man kommt da natürlich schon so ein bisschen ins Nachdenken.
Du siehst Gespenster.
Das ist schon so ein kontroverses Thema ein bisschen. Und so der ein oder andere Innenminister könnte so was schon als Gefährdung der öffentlichen Sicherheit ansehen. So ungefähr als ob es eine Bombenbauanleitung wäre. Und darum geht es mir eigentlich. Also wenn so ein System erstmal richtig etabliert ist, dann gerade wenn es intransparent ist, weiß man nicht mehr so genau, ob ein bestimmter Inhalt jetzt bloß aus irgendwelchen technischen Gründen nicht erreichbar ist oder ob er einem vorenthalten wird.
Damit alle anderen wissen, worüber Niklas redet, kaosradio.ccc.de da mal auf den Blog gucken bzw. auf kaosradio.express und dann könnt ihr euch den Podcast zum Deckpack auch noch anhören.
Also nochmal ganz kurz, ich kann dieses Gefühl, oder das ist ein Gefühl, was wir jetzt vielleicht gar nicht kennen und das ist wahrscheinlich ein Gefühl, was wir dann auch erst kennen werden, wenn diese Seiten mal gesperrt sind. Also das ist so ein ganz komisches, Moment, Internet, da klickt man halt irgendwas, dann kommt es. So, aber was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn dann irgendwelche Sachen plötzlich nicht kommen? Oder ich klick dann irgendwo, denke, vielleicht ist es irgendwo Sticheln, ist plötzlich unter Beobachtung. Und das ist natürlich ein nachvollziehbar komisches Gefühl auf jeden Fall.
Also es gibt ja diverse Länder, andere Länder, die schon Zensursysteme am Laufen haben. Das ist auch unterschiedlich. Also zum Beispiel in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten scheint es tatsächlich so zu sein, dass man dann tatsächlich so eine Fehlermeldung bekommt. Nee, darfst du nicht angucken, geht hier nicht, ist unmoralisch und so. Während in China läuft es tatsächlich so, dass es dann einfach aus Benutzerperspektive so aussieht, wie eine technische Störung. Also dass dann vielleicht jeder Zehnte schon noch durchkommt. Und die breite Matte aber eben zu faul ist, wirklich zu versuchen, sich die Inhalte zu besorgen. Darauf wird dann gebaut. Und ich würde auch sagen, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich nur um Kinderpornos geht, dann kann man das schon sperren, aber wir haben das ja in der letzten Zeit bei diversen Sicherheitsgesetzen und Überwachungsgesetzen erlebt, dass sich das immer mehr ausgedehnt hat und auf immer mehr Tatbestände angewendet wird. Und ich fürchte einfach, dass dann in ein paar Jahren zum Beispiel vor einem G8-Gipfel die Attack-Homepage so ein bisschen schwer erreichbar sein wird.
Dinge, die möglicherweise alle passieren könnten. Wir wissen es heute alle noch nicht, in diesem Januar 2009, aber wir können darüber reden. Und genau an diesem Punkt heute auch die Diskussion um Chaosradio darüber los treten. Zumindest versuchen ein paar Denkanstöße dazu zu geben. Niklas, danke dir für den Anruf. Und schönen Abend noch. Weil uns läuft jetzt ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg, weil die Kollegen vom Night Flight stehen schon vor der Tür, die hier gleich Beats basteln werden. Das heißt, kurz in die Runde noch mal so eine kleine Fazitgeschichte, bzw. Schrägschrig, haben wir irgendwas ganz Dringendes vergessen, was wir dringend noch erwähnt müssen?
Nö, außer, dass wir uns noch über Mails von euch freuen an chaosradio.ccc.de. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch was zum Thema uns mitteilen wollt, chaosradio.ccc.de. Ansonsten gibt es noch mal alles zum Nachhören, Mitlesen, Schreiben und überhaupt alles über Chaosradio unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Und den Podcast zur Sendung, und den gibt es auch bei fritz.de. Ja, wenn ihr durchsindt, dann sind wir hiermit durch. Und verbleiben mit einer Frage für die Nacht, die jeder mit unseres Kopfgesen nehmen kann. Wollen wir uns in Zukunft blinder Zensur einfach anzutrauen? In der etwas naiven Hoffnung, das Internet bleibt deswegen sauber. Chaosradio, das war's. Nächstes Chaosradio gibt es am 25. Jahr noch mal, glaube ich, wenn ich richtig gerechnet habe.
25.
Februar, ganz genau, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. chaosradio.ccc.de Danke Frank, danke Nibbler, danke Andreas und danke auch an Florian, der hier mit uns kurz telefoniert hat. Bis dann, machts gut. Tschüss.